je vais donc ouvrir j cette réunion mais
pour mieux passer la parole au président
de la délégation qui est à distance cher
dviman et je je te laisse présenter la
suite des
événements merci collègue vult donc
Mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues je
suis très heureux de voir cette nouvelle
réunion de la délégation euh aux autres
mères de l'Assemblée nationale qui se
déroule comme vous pouvez le constater
tant en en en présentiel qu' distantiel
VI la visoconférence je vous rappelle
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
diffusion en direct sur le portail de
l'Assemblée nationale et que la vidéo
sera ensuite disponible à la demande la
d'aujourd'hui sera consacrée à la
présentation du rapport de la commission
d'enquête sur la vie cher dans les autr
m cette commission d'enquête créée le 9
février 2023 a été présidée par
Guillaume vulté et Johnny haard on était
le rapporteur elle a rendu son rapport
le 20 juillet dernier après 5 mois de
travaux intenses à Paris elle a consacré
près de 70 heures euh à l'organisation
de 49 auditions qui lui ont permis
d'entendre 125 personnes
elle s'est également rendu aux Antilles
ainsi qu'à Mayotte à la Réunion où elle
a organisé 33 euh 33 auditions auou
table roundond supplémentaire la chanté
de la vie est un sujet qui concerne
l'ensemble des autres maèes les
territoires de tramarin réussisse le
paradoxe d'être à la fois ceux où le
niveau de vie est le plus faible de la
République mais aussi ceux où où le coût
de produit est le plus élevé selon l'INC
en 2022 le niveau de vie dans lesrome
est 20 à 30 % inférieur que celui dans
l'hxagone et pourtant le panier de
consommation il coûte entre 10 et 19 %
plus cher que dans l'Hexagone le rapport
passe en revue toutes les raisons pour
lesquelles les prix sont les plus élevés
l'éloignement le transport bien sûr mais
aussi des positions dominantes en
matière de transport de distribution une
concurrence pas assez développée un
nombre d'intermédiaires élevés et bien
d'autres raisons au final monsieur
monsieur rapporteur agar vous formulez
67 propositions danst une vingtaine vous
paraissent être prioritaire et que l'on
pourrait qualifier de novatrice je note
notamment que vous préconisez un
abaissement des marges des distributeurs
donc c'est la proposition 4 une fixation
réglementaire des prix de certains
produits de première nécessité
proposition 10 une majoration des
prestations sociales versées dans
lesomèes proposition 61 une tactation
des profits des grandes entreprises
opérant dans les autèes pour financer
une prime vcher 63 je constate aussi que
quelques divergences sont apparues au
sein de la commission d'enquête puisque
le président vé formule de son compé 20
minutes 21 autres préconisation le
Président propose notamment de renforcer
les moyens de l'Autorité de la
concurrence de la DGCCRF des services
fiscaux et de tous les services pouvant
concourrir au contrôle de la concurrence
à la à la répression des fraudes il
propose également que l'on s'intéresse à
l'roit de M pour réformer cet impôt en
le rendant plus lisible en
l'homogénisant et pour que certains
produits n soi exonérés je vais donc
laisser la parole au président de cette
commission d'enquête monsieur Guillaume
vult ainsi qu'au rapporteur monsieur
Johnny haard qui vont t tous nous
présenter successcessement leur travail
je vous demanderai chers collègues
d'être concis de ne pas dépasser une
quinzaine de minutes de présentation
pour permettre aux autres députés
d'apporter leurs témoignage et de poser
leurs questions vous pourrez compléter
vos propos en leur répondant monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur vous avez
la
parole
merci monsieur le Président donc comme
vous l'avez indiqué là j'interviens
aujourd'hui en tant que ex président de
la commission
d'enquête qui est en qui était chargé du
de l'examen de la vie chè are maire donc
avec un rapport qui s'appelle qui est
don le titre est pour l'égalité des
niveaux de vie dans le respect de nos
différences au travers d'un plan de
déchocage économique et social en faveur
des outres
mèes je c'est pour nous un moment
important avec notre collègue Johnny
hajard avec qui nous avonsp travaillé je
reviendrai avec vous l'avez souligné des
désaccords mais aussi beaucoup de
constats communs je pense que devant la
complexité d'une telle situation il est
naturel qu'il a des différences
d'appréciation qui parfois recoupe les
clivage politique que nous connaissons
bien mais parfois sont différents parce
que les les réalités sont complexes et
peuvent faire l'objet de différentes
approche sans qu'il y ait nécessairement
de nécessairement de comment dire de
juste position avec l'équlipage
partisan c'est un rapport de 438 pages
euh il est naturellement à disposition
de de de l'ensemble du public mais le
fait que nous passions de nous le
présentions devant la délégation des
outremèes est un moment important parce
qu'il est
évidemment c'est c'est véritablement le
lieu où les problématique ultramarine
s'exprime s'analyse se débattent et je
pense que nos concitoyens qui sont
intéressés par les sujets ultramarins
sans parler évidemment de ceux qui sont
natifs ou qui habitent l'utrem auront à
cœur de vouloir constater l'état de nos
travaux au travers de cette réunion
avant d'aborder les conclusions de ce
rapport et en demandant peut-être que
techniquement si vous ne voulez pas que
je dépasse et que je pulvérise les 15
minutes deappréciation le minur se
déplanche devant moi sinon je pense que
ma sagesse va être mise à rue d'épreuve
si jamais je n'ai pas cette cette estim
question du temps qui passe avant
d'aborder les les conclusions de du
rapport j'aimerais revenir sur le
contexte qui a donné naissance à cette
commission comme vous le savez c'est une
commission qui a été qui a
été décidé par le BIA d'un vote de
l'assemblée à l'unanimité je suis bien
convaincu que Johnny haard à mes côtés
le rappellera mais je pense qu'il a
raison de souligner ce fait le groupe
socialiste est apparenté qui avait
décidé d'inscrire une proposition de
résolution tion à son ordre du jour de
la ce qu'on appelle une niche
parlementaire a souhaité donc que cette
résolution porte sur la création de
cette commission d'enquête c'est non
seulement son droit mais c'est un
dispositif qui est
parfaitement prévu dans le cadre de de
du fonctionnement et du Règlement
Intérieur de notre assemblée évidemment
quand il y a un vote de cette nature il
y a une symbolique extrêmement forte qui
témoig d'une fait du fait d'une part de
l'acceptation de la problématique qui
est posée par l'ensemble des forces
politiques présentes à l'Assemblée mais
aussi de je pense ce moment d'attention
toute particulière euh qui qui résultait
de de ce vote montre aussi je pense
l'attachement de notre assemblée au
sujet ultramarin et au fait qu'il y ait
de nombreuses choses à faire sur ces
territoires en particulier en matière de
viecher il y a sur les territoires
ultramarins français une crise ancienne
une crise diversifiée une crise
qui qui malheureusement ne s'arrête pas
il y a des déséquilibres qui sont liés à
des années des décennies on l'a vu je
reviendrai en fin de cette intervention
à des décennies de
sous-investissement de l'État et de la
nation sur ces territoires et cette
crise durable et diversifié don des
chiffres qui sont particulement parlants
euh je reviens ici sur les données
publiques publié par par l'INC en 2017
portant sur le pourcentage de pauvreté
dans les dans les domom un pourcentage
qui est nettement plus élevé qu'en
France hexagonal 34 % en Guadeloupe 33 %
en Martinique 53 % en Guyane 42 % à la
Réunion et 77 % à Mayotte contre 14 %
sur sur sur l'exagone la faiblesse des
niveaux de vie dans les outr-omers
découle principalement de deux facteurs
d'une part les revenus mensuels sont
très faibles c'est ce que nousons de
voir au travers de ces chiffres et ne
permettent pas aux ultramarins de vivre
convenablement d'autre part le coût de
la vie en outrem est trop élevé c'est
justement ce deuxème facteur qui nous a
occupé pendant les 5 mois de la
commission d'enquête et sur lequel nous
continuons et nous continuons de
travailler la vie chè est une
problématique réelle et complexe donc
encrée durablement dans les
territoiresultremer
elle est néfaste aux populations
ultramarines et précaire précaire et les
plongent en une situation dans laquelle
elles ne peuvent se sortir sans dommage
ce phénomène concerne tous les domaines
y compris les secteurs de première
nécessité l'alimentation le logement
pour un grand mondbre d'ultramarin se
nourrir sainement à sa fin et si loin
possible en tout cas partement complexe
lorsque le niveau de vie médian s'élève
à 260 € mensuel comme c'est le cas à
Mayotte l'accès à des produits qui
valent jusqu'à trois fois plus cher
qu'en France hexagonal devient
impensable cet écart s'applique en
particulier au café au cacao à l'eau
dont on connaît aujourd'hui la la la
dimension de la crise au laitage et au
légumes les derniers chiffres de l'INC
témoignent de la précarité alimentaire
en 2022 4 à 5 personnes sur 10 affirme
ne pas pouvoir faire un repas contenant
des protéines au moins tous les 2 jours
malheureusement l'écart des biens
alimentaires n'est que le la partie
immergée de l'iceberg les écarts de prix
touchent la totalité des secteurs
ultramarins face à ces situations qui
dur depuis trop longtemps il y a donc
cette commission qui a été décidée le 9
février dernier et un mois plus tard la
commission d'enquête s'est réunie pour
constituer son bureau elle a ainsi
désigné élu monsieur Johnny hajard comme
rapporteur euh député de la Martinique
et en application de la règle qui veut
que la majorité de l'opposition se
partage la direction des travaux d'une
commission d'enquête elle m'a fait
l'honneur de me choisir comme président
en 5 mois de travaux nous avons consacré
près de 70 he pour conduire 49 auditions
qui nous ont permis d'entendre vous le
souligné tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président près de 125 personnes nous
sommes nous nous sommes également
déplacé sur le terrain en Martinique et
Saint-Martin et à la Réunion à Mayotte
où nous avons pu réaliser 33 entretiens
et table ronde je veux saluer le travail
considérable réalisé dans une ambiance
constructive et sereine avec une
participation active des 28 députés
membres issus de tous les groupes de
notre assemblée de ce travail et de cet
effort de consensus découle le présent
rapport d'enquête qui suit le plan
suivant une première partie consacrée au
coût de la vieun problème historique
dans des territoires singuliers deème
partie les outils spécifiques mis en
place pour réguler les prix outremaires
n'ont pas atteint leurs objectifs 3è
partie un état historiquement défaillant
dans ses intervention et ambigu dans sa
volonté d'agir et 4è partie la nécessité
de renouveler les outils et les
solutions ce rapport d'enquête explore
la problématique de la vie chè en
outreem à plusieurs échelles locales
nationale et régional et dans tous les
secteurs de l'outrem transport aérien
logement Télécom santé hôpital éducation
banque armateur il est la preuve d'une
démarche de notre commissionidentif de
notre commission pour une idtification
et l'analyse de tous les facteurs qui
entraînent la chté de la vie en are mer
quant au résultats de ce rapport bien
que nous ayons mené un travail commun de
qualité avec Monsieur haard des
divergences existent sur différents
points que je voudrais souligner
aujourd'hui encore une fois ces
divergences ne me paraissent pas
choquant encore elles résultent de la
complexité des des sujets et aussi des
différentes appréciations politiques que
nous avons mais la démocratie est ainsi
faite et c'est très heureux premièrement
je regrette que le rapporteur ait eu
parfois une compréhension trop globale
du sujet ce qui donne le sentiment que
le rapport vient souvent en simple
justification de l'exposé des motifs de
la proposition de résolution je ne suis
pas certain que le lecteur tire à
l'issus de sa lecture une réponse claire
à la question posée aussi selon moi il y
a une part de l'explication de la vie
chère qui ne fait pas débat les
territoires ultramarins ont en commun
d'être lointain insulaair et ou quasi
insulaire la Guyane a une forme de mer
végétale autour d'elle avec l'Amazonie
représentant des marchés de taille
limité et en très grande contrainte un
marché limité lointain dont les seules
voies d'approvisionnement nécessitent de
long trajet en M est un marché dont le
fonctionnement est coûteux il faut
reconnaître cette évidence et son impact
considérable sur les prix mais la
question de savoir si d'autres causes
tenant au comportement des acteurs de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement en
particulier joue aussi un rôle qui
viendrait surabonder le phénomène je
rejoint ainsi le rapporteur à cet égard
quand il écrit que la multiplication des
intermédiaires pour l'approvisionnement
est sans doute l'occasion
multiplication des marges que chacun
d'entre eux s'octroit la question des
responsabilités de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et d'une part de
savoir s'il existe des acteurs dont le
rôle est
superfetatoire et dans la marge réalisée
est injustifiée et dont les détaillant
ultramarins pourrai se passer facilement
je ne crois pas que notre enquête ait
fait apparaître de tels acteurs même les
grossistes importateurs dont le pouvoir
de marché peut être important selon les
marques et les produits ont été décrits
comme nécessaires au fonctionnement des
marchés s'ils sont en perte de vitesse
face au développement de l'provis
inement direct depuis les centrales
d'achat hexagonal et c'est la principale
évolution qui a connu le commerce de
détail ultramarin ces dernières années
il fournit des services indispensable
même si cher du fait de leur possibilité
d'importer de stocker de placer en
magasin les produits des plus grandes
marques qui constituent le modèle de
consommation commun à l'Hexagone et aux
autres mè l'autre question est de savoir
si l'un ou l'autre de ces acteurs peut
bénéficier d'un pouvoir de marché qui
lui permett de peser significativement
et à son profit sur les prix d'un
produit il existe ement des monopoles ou
ou des oligopoles de fait il est
complexe de déterminer s'il constiue des
barrières à l'entrée d'autres acteurs ou
si ces situations ne résultent pas de la
taille et des contraintes de
fonctionnement des différents marchés en
tant que tels à cet égard pour prendre
la situation du fret fondamental dans
des économies insulaires il me semble
pas ressortir de nos auditions des des
documents obtenus que l'observateur
numéro 1 dans la desserte des
outres-mers cherche à augmenter indument
ses marges mais qu'il essaie plutôt de
favoriser un parcours de livraison qui
permette à approvisionnement régulier
des territoires il y a davantage un
sujet relatif aux incidents de livraison
qui pose de réelles difficultés quant à
l'approvisionnement en produits
frais qui qui impose des capacités de
stockage très élevé le rapporteur est
par ailleurs convaincu que l'intégration
verticale des différents éléments de la
chaîne de constitution des prix donne en
tant que tel un pouvoir de marché
exorbitant et qu'une telle situation
existe notamment au sein du groupe GBH
il s'inscrit en cela dans les
témoignages à charge d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs mais je ne peux passer sous
silence que le groupe GBH nous a adressé
un courrier qui cont qui contredit
formellement ses conclusions et apporte
un nombre d'éléments à cet effet c'est
une conséquence directe de la
transférence de nos débats que cette
concentration verticale existe qu'elle
permette une technicité une connaissance
des contraintes spécifiques de
laapprovisionnement Remire ou qu'elle
soit sans nul doute source de profit est
une chose que ces Provis soient
excessifs et à l'origine de la chareté
de la vie en tant que telle en est une
autre j'ai à cet égard un avis plus
nuancé que le rapporteur en revanche là
où nous tomberons pleinement d'accord
c'est c'est sur la faiblesse des moyens
que déploie l'État pour caractériser et
combattre les éventuelles pratiques
anticoncurrentielles qui peuvent exister
que ce soit sur les services de
protection des consommateurs ou de
répression des fraudes des organes de
contrôle comme les opmr et sans doute
les douanes l'appareil public qui doit
garantir un fonctionnement concurrentiel
du marché n'est aujourd'hui pas à la
hauteur il ne permet d'ailleurs pas de
faire respecter des lois qui ont été
voté même très récemment je pense en
particulier à la loi Lurel et des lois
pant sur ce qu'on appelle des marges
arrières où la réalité de la
contractualisation commerciale n'est pas
toujours vérifiable et où la pratique
proscrite de vente forcée des services
de mise en rayon paraît pourtant
subsister je crois par ailleurs que
l'obligation de dépôt des comptes doit
être respectée par l'instauration de
sanctions comparablement plus sévère que
celle qui existe et qu'il est nécessaire
comme dans l'Hexagone qu'elle soit
général que soit généralisée la
transmission au services fiscaux
d'étiquets de
caisse ce que je note c'est que la
présence d'une concurrence dynamique est
la meilleure garantie d'une pression
vertueuse sur les prix comme on peut le
voir dans le cas des fournisseurs
d'accès Internet une telle concurrence
permet à tous les acteurs solvables
d'entrer sur les marchés où les prix
sont maintenus excessivement élevés
grâce à des accords tacites entre
quelques acteurs quelques mots sur le
bouclier prix qui est en cours
d'ensemble de territoire personne ne nit
son impact sur le pouvoir d'achat des
habitants cependant la question de son
périmètre se pose car de nombreux points
de vente de proximité choisissent de ne
pas l'appliquer ce qui limite son
efficacité il est également important de
noter que dans ce dispositif les
distributeurs font des efforts en R dans
leur marge les collectivités limitent le
T d'octroit de mer mais l'État ne
contribue pas financièrement ce qui
soulève des questions qui méritent une
réponse d'autres freins parfois absurdes
pèent sur les prix je pense en
particulier à la problématique des
normes dont nous avons retrouvé des
exemples en particulier dans les
surcouts de construction les normes
européennes relatives à l'importation de
matériaux de construction me paraissent
me paraissent une aberération elle pèse
sur le coût des logements dans le
territoire d'outrem pourquoi la
tarification élevée des matériaux de
construction découle principalement de
de coup associé aux importations en
effet l'Hexagone demeure le principal
partenaire commercial des régions des
régions ultrapériphériques cette
dynamique d'échange est très
problématique dans la mesure où les
coûts engendrés par les importations de
ces matériaux se répercutent sur le prix
final du logement les territoires
d'outremè sont en effet obligés
d'importer les matériaux de construction
depuis l'Europe continentale en
application de la réglementation de
l'Union européenne une réglementation
qui finit par peser sur le budget des
ménages euh il existe donc une
incohérence normative qui émane de
l'absence des échanges commerciaux à
l'échelle régionale en fonction de la
nonconformité aux normes européennes dit
marquage chez Rue cet aspect a été très
souligné par les acteurs de la TBL rond
logement auditionné je pense que cela
pour devrait pouvoir trouver une
solution prochainement puisque il y aura
bientôt euh so autorisé un marquage
dérogatoire RUP qui permettra de lever
un son nombre de euh de questions et
surtout de trouver des adaptations des
corances de normes qui sans revenir sur
la qualité et sur la sécurité
permettrant un approvisionnement de
proximité euh d'ailleurs si on devait
trouver un exemple caricatural c'est
celui de Saint-Martin où les deux
parties de l'Î ne peuvent pas connecter
leur réseau d'eau pour des raisons de
différence de normees et je ne crois pas
qu'aucune des deux parties voit des gens
mourir de voir de l'eau de l'un ou de
l'autre il y a des points aussi nous
avons nous avons des
divergences je pense que les
surrémunérations sont un sujet qui qui
mérite d'être abordé non pas pour les
remettre en cause c'est une aide de plus
d'un milliard et demi d'euros qui permet
aux économiesrires aussi de fonctionner
mais en revanche cela donne aussi à peu
près une petite moitié de de la
population qui a un niveau de vie
solevable au niveau des prix qui existe
en autre m alors même que l'autre partie
est en très très grande difficulté que
ce soit les personnes âgées les chômeurs
ou euh les jeunes et les personnes en
grande précarité il y a donc une
nécessité d'essayer de retrouver une
homogénéité des revenus en notutre m et
cela passe non pas par la réduction à
mon sens de la surrémunération mais
plutôt par l'augmentation du revenus des
autres parties de la population et par
une limination des des économies je
crois en celace qu'il y a un effort de
formation à faire en particulier je
pense au RSMA mais je crois aussi qu'il
y a des efforts à faire en terme d'accès
au droit et je pense en particulier aux
personnes âgées avec le la faible le
faible usage de laallocation de
solidarité pour les personnes âgées par
exemple il y a un sujet sur l'octroit de
mer qui est un serpent de mer le le sium
l'a fait abordé avec beaucoup de
prudence et je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose euh pensez que d'un coup de
bagette magique le remplacement de l'ro
de mer par une TVA va résoudre les
problèmes est une illusion je pense que
prix s' s'en ressentira enfin ne
changera pas beaucoup voire même pour
augmenter parce qu'on va appliquer la
TVA à tous alors même que l'ctroit de
mer cible maintenant il y a des
difficultés qui existe je pense que le
fait que l' de mer soit payé en amont de
la vente est un sujet je pense que l' de
mer puisse varier trop fréquemment est
un sujet et je pense que le TR n'est pas
de de cohérence au niveau de la
au niveau des des au moins des bassins
océaniques est un sujet c'est la CRÉ une
forme de de de de comment dire de
concurrence entre les territoires
dernier point que je vaux que je
voudrais aborder dans les quelques
secondes qui me restent c'est celui des
collectivités locales mais je le fais
aussi pour que nous puissions discuter
avec le le rapporteur àjard il y a des
je crois que c'est Jean-Victor castor
qui citait lors de notre examen de
budget il y a lundi le fait qu'il y
avait des compagnies qui euh ferm faute
d'avoir été payé par les administrations
d'État il a raison mais pas que c'est
vrai aussi d' somble de collectivité
local qui n'honoront pas leur leur
facture en temps et en heur mettent en
jeu l'existence de compagnie Les
contratcom répondent nous avons les
augmentés dans le dans le dans ce budget
il faut pours cet effort de de
restructuration des finances locales
nous avons eu un budget qui a été
examiné le 6 de façon partielle pour des
raisons de règles de fonctionnement
notre assemblée
je crois qu'il a apporté un débat malgré
tout de qualité euh qui a permis des
échanges c'est un processus qui sera
long le budget ne s'arrête pas à la
première lecture nous avons à obtenir du
gouvernement des avancé je crois que
johnyard a voulu par des amendements
massifs montrer ce que voulait dire la
notion de déchocage mais il aura
l'occasion de d'en parler d'ici très peu
de temps euh peut-être pourra-t-il
fonctionner comme ça ou peut-être
parfois un peu différemment ce que je
crois c'est que ce rapport aura pu
contribuer à faire prendre conscience à
l'ensemble des acteurs publics
parlementairire mais aussi gouvernement
que cette question de la vie chère et de
l'écart entre les revenus et le niveau
de vie en outrem est fondamental et que
l'avenir des outrem s'écrira parce que
nous aurons aussi réussi à résoudre tout
tout parti de ce problème je vous
remercie
merci cher collègue
cèg bien merci bonjour à toutes et à
tous ceux qui sont présents physiquement
ceux qui sont loin
méprisents par la
visio d'abord vous dire merci parce que
toutes les personnes qui sont présentes
sont des personnes qui ont contribué de
près ou de loin et je pense à
l'administration aussi puisque je vois
Gabriel et puis toutes les personnes
qu'on travaillé même sur la
communication et donc je voulais
vraiment remercier les personnes qu'on
ne voit pas qu'on entend pas parce que
certains appellent les petites mains moi
j'appelle les grandes mains parce que
elles sont certainement plus importantes
que nous nous ne sommes que les
animateurs d'une action globale au
service de l'intérêt général donc merci
ce
rapport me paraît un rapport
aujourd'hui très clair et très réaliste
il est sans
concession il n'est pas à
charge il doit servir de base de départ
d'un nouveau modèle économique l'enjeu
fondamentalement il est là que
voulons-nous dans le cadre et dans le
respect de la République française pour
nos territoires dans le respect de nos
différences Paris n'est pas fort de
France les problèmes de Mayot ne sont
pas nécessairement les mêmes problèmes
comme Martinique maot et la GU on un
problème d'immigration nous on a un
problème de dépeuplement les réalités de
nos territoires sont très différentes
entre territoire dit d'outremè eux-même
d'ailleurs il va falloir travailler sous
ce vocable parce que ultraarin qui est
outremè est-ce que c'est la France qui
est-ce que c'est nous qui qui sommes r
c'est un vrai sujet mais nous sommes
comme le franceçis de l'Hexagone comme
le Breton comme le Marseillais des
peuples aussi dignes humainement je
regarde ma collègue polynésienne et je
rêve d'aller en Polynésie parce que nous
sommes de passage et que nous avons une
mission à accomplir nous avons choisi
l'intérêt général donc comment est-ce
que dans le respect de la République on
peut agir concrètement pour c'est quoi
l'objectif au fond améliorer le
quotidien de nos peuples et de nos
populations améliorer le vivre ensemble
dans une dynamique
d'émancipation considérons que nous
existons tous par nous-mêmes sans avoir
à avoir on va dire une position sociale
sans avoir sans mettre l'argent comme
étant au cœur du pouvoir ce n'est pas
une question
d'argent c'est une question de dignité
humaine de respect de vivre ensemble
donc ce rapport il représente il respire
tout ça je va faire très simple he je
pense que le le constat on le partage
tous donc je va pas passer beaucoup de
temps sur le constat nous sommes tous
des personnes qui connaissons les autres
mères de près ou de loin dans leur
réalité propre mais aussi dans le cadre
de la République française et même je
mets Guillaume aussi Guillaume connaît
bien
et même si on a des différences ce sont
des différences certainement sur les
solutions que nous pensons apporter mais
je vais peut-être passer quelques
minutes sur la méthode parce que je veux
pas reprendre ce qu'il a dit quelle
était la méthode choisie on a un
problème qui est au-dessus de tout quand
je dis qui auudessus de tout parce que
la conséquence de la vie cher c'est
l'insécurité c'est les crises sociales
c'est mati économique c'est problématiqu
de logement c'est problématiqu éduca
c'est que tout ce que nous vivons dans
le quotidien Aujourd'hui de nos enfants
à l'école de l'insécurité de la drogue
du problème économique de la vie chè des
problèmes de logement des problèmes de
l'hôpital c'est lié au coût de la vie
dans les territoires qui sont régis
pararticle 73 et 74 c'est ça le fond du
problème alors comment changer de
paradigme c'est très simple il faut
avoir une vision globale le médecin
regarde le patient il lui pose des
questions il identifie les symptômes et
recherche sans oublier aucun symptôme
parce que on a trop souvent regardé la
vie chè comme un problème des prix qui
augmentent oui les prix qui augmentent
sont un élément et une caractéristique
de la vi chair mais ça ne suffit pas
pour expliquer la vie chè ah oui on a
regardé sur l'insularité l'éloignement
l'exiguité des marchés j'entend
Guillaume le dit oui structurellement la
position de la Martinique vis-à-vis de
la France ne va pas changer sauf le bon
Dieu a décidé de nous rapprocher comme
l'Accord à 600 km des côes Françaises ça
va pas changer peut-être un jour ça ça
changera mais avec la techonique des
plaques peut-être qu'un jour ça viendra
mais pour le moment c'est
structurel la différence de mon approche
avec Guillaume c'est que oui
l'insularité est une réalité on est une
île entourée d'eau pour la plupart sauf
la
Guyane et nous avons nos différences et
nous sommes exigus parce que nous avons
les marchés qui sont plus petits en
théorie je vais vous dire pourquoi en
théorie mais dans la réalité même si on
est 8000 km 20000 km de la France qui
est notre principal lieu
d'approvisionnement puceque nous sommes
français 80 % de ce que nous consommons
c'est le modèle économique dans lequel
nous sommes dans la France nous impose
de consommer et de faire venir des
marchandises de très loin de très
loin c'est ça le problème qui est posé
au fond mais là je ne le rejoins pas
mais c'est pour vous éclairer c'est pas
c'est en toute
amicalité c'est que ce que l'on appelle
des problèmes structurels ne sont sont
pas une fatalité ce n'est pas parce que
c'est une réalité qu'il n'y a pas des
moyens de les compenser et de les
régler et je pose dans les solutions que
je vous présente c'est pour ça qu'il
faut d'abord bien comprendre la méthode
approche
globale qu'est-ce qui fait la vie
chè on est tous partis sur les niveaux
des prix et ben non le premier critère
c'est le niveau des revenu le premier
déterminant c'est le niveau de revenu
oui nos niveaux de revenu sont très
largement inférieur à ceux du territoire
de l'Hexagone les chiffres de li le
montrent on en peut prendre plusieurs
chiffres mais je va pasendre martinque
1360 € par mois de niveau de vie Médi en
France c'est 1700 € il y en a d'aresot
c'est 260 € donc c'est encore pire si je
prends le niveau de vie
médian le plus élevé chez nous c'est
17000 € en
Martinique en France c'est 24000 € en
île- de France le niveau de vie médium
vous voyez l'écart qu'il y a ces
inégalités ce que le constat du rapport
monre c'est que ces inégalités plutôt
que de se réduire et c'est là où il faut
qu'on soit honnête je pardon c'est pas
pour Guillaume que je dis ça mais
honnête dans la matérialisation dans la
formalisation de ce qui se passe les
inégalités n'ont pas arrêté de
s'accroître depuis la
départementalisation c'est ça qu'il faut
entendre aujourd'hui c'est un fait c'est
factuel on prend n'importe quel secteur
les inégalités se sont accrues ce que
les prix montent alors premier niveau
niveau du revenu quelle conséquence
extrême précarité chômage extrême
pauvreté pauvreté c'est la situation
actuelle d'une grande majorité de celles
et ceux qui n'ont pas de quoi manger
boire dans nos territoire manger boire
c'est la dignité humaine ça passe par ça
d'abord le deuxème
déterminant c'est le niveau des prix oui
le niveau des prix agit et là quand on
rentre dans la question des niveaux des
prix
oui la question du transport rent en
compte la question de la formation des
prix la question de la fiscalité mais
autant je peux accepter de voir et
d'entendre parler de l' de mer autant je
veux qu'on parle de la TVA ne pas
regarder un problème sur un seul bout
sur un seul segment parce qu'on se
trompe parce que les solutions seront
partiellires vous regardez un problème
partiellement vous aurez des solutions
partiell et c'est pour ça que les
solutions de différents états enfin des
différents des différents
gouvernements qui ont composé l'
histoire de l'état de la France n'ont
jamais réussi parce qu'ils ont toujours
regardé le problème de nos territoirees
d'un petit bout de morceau de problème
en disant je donne un peu plus d'argent
je donne 40 % je je mets un abattement
fiscal à 30 % et bien la TVA elle a 20 %
en France je la mets à 85 je la mets à
25 et à force de regarder ça et ben on a
fait des pensements surous des petites
jambes de côter et on a rien réglé du
tout parce que les problèmes d'ordre
structurel et conjoncturel demeur ils se
sont aggravés avec le covid
conjoncturellement ils vont s'aggraver
encore avec l'Ukraine ils vont
s'aggraver encore avec le risque
géopolitique de guerre mondiale qui va
arriver plus les risques climatiques ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
la première fois que ce rapport
s'attaque un problème de fond qui est
quelles sont les causes structurelles il
faut ajouter les causes conjonctuelles
parce que le temps passe on évolue
j'avais 20 ans il a 20 ans Ben
aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai 18 ans allez on y
va je grandis pas je je je grand dis en
sageos mais je baisse en âge civil c'est
pour taquiner tout le monde donc
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là le
niveau des prix ça nous amène dans les
dans la réalité du modèle économique
historique dans lequel nous sommes
oligopole monopole j'apprends rien à
personne sauf que ce que j'apprends aux
autres c'est que il y a une
concentration verticale et une
concentration horizontale qui s'est
consolidé c'est quoi la concentration
verticale quand vous avez la maîtrise de
la chaîne d'approvisionnement de depuis
l'industriel jusqu'au transporteur
jusqu'au transport jusqu'à grossiste
importateur jusqu'au distributeur
c'està-dire le consommateur final vous
maîtrisez la chaîne quand vous maîtrisez
la chaîne vous faites des économies
d'échelle en économie ça s'appelle des
économies d'échelle quand en plus vous
avez les moyens d'optimiser fiscalement
et bien oui la multiplication des
intermédiaires devient un vrai problème
parce que chaque intermédiaire c'est une
marge une marge avant donc afficher que
tout le monde vois et une marge arrière
et ça ce rapport là c'est ça qu'il
montre c'est que derrière les marges
avant il y a les Marg mer don personne
ne parle comme elles sont arrière comme
on dit en criole en bffille c'est sous
la feuille on ne la voit pas martinque
je veux apprendre un polynésien en
réunion et autre mais comme c'est en
dessous comme c'est derrière les marges
arrièr n'apparaissent pas personne n'en
parle ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on rajoute marge avant et marge
arrière et les prix ne baissent jamais
et qu'est-ce que le rapport de lin monte
les écarts de prix entre la France
hexagonal les outremèes là là 2022 n'ont
jamais été aussi important maintenant
qu'avant c'estàdire que les écarts de
prix se sont creusés pourtant la
Martinique ne s'est pas éloigné de la
France la guyan non plus on est on n'est
pas passé de 8000 km à 20000 km de
distance notre position géographique n'a
pas changé et pourtant les écarts de
prix continuent de se creuser donc le
rapport apporte la réponse les marges ne
baissent pas les prix continuent
d'augmenter donc le consommateur final
continue d'être a Tage d'une situation
de marché fermé ben oui pourquoi le
marché fermé parce que les seuls moyens
d'approvisionnement c'est par le bateau
je dis même pas l'aérien parce que c'est
quelques produits qui viennent par
l'aérien ça sent que ça coûte encore
beaucoup plus cher par l'aérien le seul
moyen de déplacement de mobilité humain
pour nous dans nos territoirees c'est
l'avion
le seul moyen de récupérer des
marchandises c'est par le bateau donc on
est contraint par rapport au français de
la France hexagonal c'est une réalité
vous avez le train vous avez la route
vous avez l'Europe les lieux
d'approvisionnement ne sont pas les
mêmes nous on nous impose comme
approvisionnement la France on a des
marchés
caribéens régionaux dont la diplomatie
territoriale on est étranger à notre
propre diplomatie on n'est pas capable
de négocier nous-même pour avoir de la
marchandise moins cher bien sûr avec une
équivalence norme parce qu'il faut
maintenir la sécurité des normes mais
c'est pas une équivalence qui écrase la
norme et qui empêche de recevoir comme
on a vu à Saint-Martin de l'eau je parle
parce que j'ai vu France gums là il y a
des territoires qui ont des doubles
insularités je pense à Mayotte on est
obligé de passer par la Réunion pour la
Mayotte on est obligé de passer par la
guadoup par Saint-Martin donc il y a des
territoires qui sont très différents
donc le niveau des prix est un problème
il me reste 3 minutes mais
et bon sousfinancement des collectivités
territoriales j'ai déjà expliqué l'état
enlevé de l'argent au recettes des
Collectiv é territoriale et
désengagement de l'État l'état
aujourd'hui investit moins dans des
territoirees finance moins et participe
moins à l'action publique les solutions
quelles sont-ils parce que je vois que
le temps passe vite j'ai fait beaucoup
de solutions les solutions passent par
plusieurs choses très
simplement baiss baisser les prix ça
c'est une chose mais il faut d'abord
augmenter les revenus augmenter les
revenus de ceux qui travaillent
augmenter le revenus de ceux qui ne
travaill pas pour ceux qui ne
travaillent pas c'est les les
allocations sociales qu'il faut majorer
à travers une TVA affecté
pour que les majorations parce que la
loocation familiale aujourd'hui ou le
RSA il est du même montant en France et
en Martinique sauf que la vie plus cher
en Martinique donc un res à 400 € en
Martinique alors que la vie est beaucoup
plus cher que pour un Français qui vit
en France qui touche le même RSA il peut
pas consommer de la même manière il n'a
pas le pouvoir de dignité de vie je
disais que les monopoles les oligopoles
ce sont des faiseurs de prix hein j'ai
oublié de dire ça il décident des prix
c'est déterminé ils décident des prix
des marchés ils ont le pouvoir de
marcher ils ont même pouvoir d'influence
auprès des gouvernements je considère
que maintenant ils arrivent à un niveau
ils sont tellement influents qu'ils ont
même peut-être même plus puissants que
certains états attention mais je reviens
au mesure mesure à court terme les
mesures à court terme c'est permettre
aux gens qui n'ont pas de quoi manger
boire de manger donc les produits de
première nécessité il faut bloquer les
prix il faut arrêter de jouer et de
rigoler la grande distribution c'est
40000 références quand vous bloquez les
prix sur 300 références vous n'avez rien
fait de mal vous n'avez rien fait de mal
euh le groupe GBH dit qu'il est prêt à
monter à 2800 mais oui 2800 c'est normal
puisque 40 sur 2800 c'est toujours pas
grandchose on peut bloquer les prix
arrêtez de faire comme si nous ne savons
pas et nous ne connaissons pas les
choses on peut bloquer les prix sur plus
de 3000 produits pour faire en sorte que
les gens mangent boisent dorment et
vivent on peut faire compenser alors la
solution c'est quoi oui déchocage
économique et social massif quand le
malade est à terre et il n'a plus de
quoi respirer il faut pendant la
première période il faut il faut que des
interventions extérieures viennent donc
l'État doit venir réguler ce qui n'est
pas régulé aujourd'hui ce qui est de la
dimension de la puissance comique et
donc comment faire ça très simplement
par des exonérations fiscales et
sociales pour les très petites et
moyennes entreprises pour leur permettre
de recruter localement donc donner un
salaire aux personnes qui sont au
chômage donc leur donner au travail
comment faire ça en faisant des
activités intermédiaire que l'on crée
localement qui leur permettent de créer
on va dire des produits intermédiaires
qu'on peut faire repartir vers la France
j'ai beaucoup de mesures les mesures
d'augmentation des niveaux de revenus
passent par la mise à jour des
allocation familiale pare une TVA pas
affectée passe aussi par la création
d'emploi et d'activité pour ceux qui
n'ont pas d'emploi donc un salaire à
travers justement la possibilité de
baisser les charges des entreprises
pendant 10 ans comme il baissent les
charge l'entreprise a comme condition de
recruter augmenter leur marché notre
marché et là c'est très important il me
reste 10 secondes mais Guillaum le
marché aujourd'hui c'est le marché
français mais si on ouvre notre marché à
la Caraïbe je prends exemple la grande
carïbe c'est plus de 40 millions
d'habitants notre marché est très ouvert
donc la question de l'étroitesse des
marchés intérieur n'est plus structurel
parce que nous avons ouvert notre marché
et si on arrive à mettre des conditions
d'exportation je prend un exemple tout
simple aujourd'hui la cmacgm ceux qui
font venir des conteneurs ils payent
laaller tout en une fois parce queils
n'ont rien à faire repartir avec la
cmcgm qui continue à payer le carburant
et cetera et cetera qui un monopole he
quasi monopole 80 % par on parler des
monopoes il y a pas que les grand
groupes économiques orange pour moi est
dans un oligopole sur l'Internet parce
qu'ils ont les câbles sous-marins donc
ils distribuent le prix de l'Internet
comme ils le veulent 35 % plus cher
pourquoi alors qu'ils ont amorti déjà le
câ sous-marin depuis des années il faut
pouvoir avoir des câes publicqus pour
maîtriser ce sujet-là la continuité
territoriale model Corse bien sûr mais
quand je disais qu'il faut augmenter les
revenus on a la possibilité d'augmenter
les tailles de marché on a augmenté la
possibilité de de de sécuriser la
l'exportation parce qu'il faut augmenter
la production locale aller vers de la
diversification par rapport à nos
réalités de de ce que nous avons euh la
Nouvelle-Calédonie la Réunion il y a
d'autres territoires qu'on des richesses
la Guyane mais nous aussi on a des
richesses en matière de biodiversité
mais qu'il faut exploiter donc il faut
créer des filières mais en attendant il
y a un plan d'action à mettre en place à
court terme moyen terme et long terme le
court terme là c'est de permettre au
plus défavorisé de manger boire de
dormir d'investir pour que dans quelques
années on puisse par le biais des
exonérations fiscales et sociales sur 10
ans permettre de créer de l'activité
pour créer de l'emploi en créant des
filières en ouvrant le marché en
sécurisant les marchés et en nous
redonnant de la dignité parce que
l'ingénierie locale martiniicaaise
guadeloupéenne réunionnaise polynésienne
existe il faut leur donner cette
capacité de se développer parce que
quand on dit oui les Corum c'est bien
mais c'est pas suffisant parce que
derrière quand on a rendu exangle les
collectivités territoriales pas par
elle-même si elle ne paye pas les
entreprises à mais c'est normal vous
baissez les recettes à rien les charges
elles elles explosent mais en plus la
mairie ou la collectivité elle doit
équilibrer ses comptes parce que le la
Cour des comptes tindit de vouster un
compte en déséquilibre ce qui pas le cas
de l'État donc on impose finalement de
diminuer les niveaux de service public
au lieu de faire quatre ramassage au'h
au ménagur il va en faire deux au lieu
de boucher plus de trous il va boucher
moins de trous au lieu de de d'améliorer
l'habitat dans l'éducation nationale les
équipements qui ont été transférés et
ben il va dépenser moins d'argent pour
l'entretien des bâtiments publics et
puis comme ça ne suffit pas et ben il
est obligé d'augmenter les taxes et et
et et les les impôts locaux mais
derrière vous alle augmenter des taxes
et des impôts sur des gens qui n'ont
déjà plus de moyens la classe moyenne
c'est appauvri hein aujourd'hui 90 % de
nos peuples et de nos populations sont
auj'hui dans des situations
difficiles incapable de vivre donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ce plan
là est un plan global qui peut se
décliner c'est pour ça que parmi les
mesures je considère et ça c'est
important dans la méthode c'est pas pour
la Martinique c'est pas pour la
guadeloup c'est pour chacun
singulièrement séparément j'ai fait un
panier comme il fallit donner la
possibilité à chacun de pouvoir trouver
sa propre
recette on va dire son propre vêtement
qui soit sa taille sa propre taille de
chaussure sa propre taille de
fonctionnement l'idée c'est de se dire
et bien on met des mesures et chaque
territoire choisit ce qui l'intéresse ou
pas il y a des mesures sur l'évolution
institutionnelle ce que ça n'intéresse
pas ça n'intéresse pas il y a des
mesures économiques ce qui inér
inéress'intéresse pas parce que il y a
des gens qui sont dans des régimes il y
a des gens des collectivités dans le 73
dans le 74 donc il faut pouvoir dans ce
panier que chacun la Polynésie la
Guadeloupe la Réunion Mayot et cetera
puisse faire son marché dire voilà les
mesures qui m'intéressent mais pour
pouvoir les mettre en forme leur donner
un sens un chemin une cohésion il faut
mettre en place d'abord les étages
généux de la vchè dans chaque territoire
je vous invite chaque camarade faites
les états généraux de la vichère dans
vos territoirees vous allez réunir tout
le monde les grands groupes les petits
groupe les acteurs économiques les
forces vives associatives les
collectivités locales les élus et vous
définissez sur les 10 prochaines années
le chemin de construction d'un
développement endogène pensé localement
par la dimension collective et
l'intelligence collective qui
permettrait à chacun de pouvoir
construire un avenir meilleur un vivre
ensemble et une intelligence collective
je dis ça pour finir en disant
simplement parce qu'il faut laisser la
parole à
vous-même il faut changer de paradigme
faudra changer de modèle économique mais
chacun a en main le destin de son
territoire parce que nous avons une
responsabilité vous savez ces dit tous
les hommes ont même droit mais du coup
l' c plus de devoir que d'autres nous en
tant que parlementairire nous avons été
missionnés par nos peuples respectifs
nous avons l'obligation et le droit de
nous imposer en unité par nous-mêm mais
au sein de la République en partenariat
en solidarité fraternellement avec
Guillaume avec mode avec d'autres parce
que mode des martiniquez hein elle est
député de France mais martinquez
excusez-moi mais avec d'autres avec
d'autres des députés français de
l'Hexagone qui comprennent la réalité
j'ai un travail de conscientisation à
mener au niveau de l'ensemble des
parlementaires nous ne sommes pas un
appendice nous sommes la richesse de la
France et je disais ça au au au au
ministrees on vous nous parlez de 6
milliards de 1 milliard de 300 milliards
mais est-ce que vous avez traduit
financièrement converti les milliers de
milliards de milliards de milliards que
nous apportons en rayonnement
géostratégique en rayonnement euh euh
euh écologique envonnement naturel et
également
en en milieu maritime par exemple quand
je disait que la Martinique c'est 1000
km² ok c'est petit mais c'est 44000 km²
de zone économique exclusive donc si la
France c'est la deuxè puissance maritime
mondial depuis non non ben c'est grâce à
ces richesses là ben mettons dans la
balance ces richesses là aussi donc vous
voulez je dis je parle à l'état je parle
pas gouvernement vous
voulez la puissance maritime la
puissance géostratégique la puissance
écologique la puissance géothermique la
puissance naturelle et puis en face on
donne des miettes sans possibilité pour
nous d'avoir la capacité de penser par
nous-même notre propre développement
deogène dans le respect de la République
dans le niveau de relation que nous
voulons avec la France moi je suis
français et je l'affirme et je le
maintiens mais je suis aussi martinqueel
mes amis je suis aussi caribéen et je
suis ultraarin parce que je suis
solidaire de la Polynésie de la guadoup
de la Guyane et des régions françaises
aussi qui ont besoin que la
différenciation soit reconnu nous sommes
égaux ici mais nous avons besoin de
notre égalité
humaine de sortir de toute forme de
domination soumission et de rentrer dans
une égalité réelle en terme de droit des
personnes humaines à la vivre dignement
mais surtout surtout très important dans
le respect de nos différences de notre
identité et de notre culture et je
terminerai par cette phrase de c encore
vous m'excusez je suis un césériste
progressiste ce n'est pas par la tion du
singulier que l'on va à l'universel mais
c'est par l'approfondissement du
singulier que nous allons à l'universel
allons à dans un universel humaniste
universaliste dans l'approfondissement
de nos singularités dans nos différences
mais dans le respect de la République
ensemble en fraternité
merci
Président c'est vous qui reprenez la
main maintenant c'est le président de
la
merci au de
collègues bon la réception est un peu
Longtain dans nos territoire
malheureusement alors super pour
l'intervention alors euh est-ce qu'il y
a des collègues au premier abord qui
souhaitit poser des questions déjà à à
nos deux
collègues président bonsoir tu vas
bien bonsoir chers collègue dans la
parole apparemment avoir euh comment
dirait ton dress code là tu dois être
dans un pays un peu
tempéré voilà voilà suppose que la Guan
fait partie des
territoires avec une bonne température
oui voilà donc déjà pour remercier et
féliciter euh le président euh de cette
commission et particulièrement le
rapporteur écoutez à vous entendre on
pourrait donc nous en aller et pour
parcourir euh le rapport qu'on vient de
recevoir à
l'instant j'ai été tellement passionné
conquis par cette mission que je n'avais
même pas fait attention que j'étais pas
membre de cette commission là et j'ai
participé à mon nombre d'auditions
pardonnez-moi mon intrusion disons
régulière si vousorisez chers collègues
c'est un des point de méthode que nous
avons tenu à faire alors je l'avais
précisé lors du début c'est que
évidemment il y a une répartition la
proportionnelle des groupes qui se fait
dans une commission d'enquête mais pour
nous il était inenvisageable que
l'ensemble des équipes ultramarins qui
souhaitent y participer ne puissent pas
le faire donc on a systématiquement fa
fait suivre toutes les invitations à
l'ensemble des membres de la D pour être
bien sûr que chacun soit informé de la
progression de nos nos travaux et donc
il n'y avait pas de différence en en
réalité à part au moment du vote puisque
c'était forcément lot voilà merci
président euh je disais donc de me
pardonner mon inclusion régulière
chronique et
assidu mais là j'ai pas Cu ça j'aimerais
juste avoir quelques monsieur rapporteur
sur quelques un et bon vous féliciter
pour on a plusieurs dizaines de disons
de propositions de recommandation mais
j'aimerais donc sur la proposition 4
est-ce qu'on peut avoir disons quelqu
éclaircissement et voir comment on
pourrait mettre ça en place faire en
sorte que ces messieurs puissent baisser
les les prix de 10 à 20 % et la
proposition 18 non pas pas 18 alors oui
la la
12 contrôler les concentrations are mère
comment on s'y prend si la chose a
fonctionné
euh peut-être en Nouvelle-Calédonie
peut-être je sais pas mais faut regarder
comment on pourrait mettre ça en en
place voilà un peu mes mes deux
questions bon le reste on va pouvoir
lire ça tranquillement
euh et Jny sera toujours pour nous une
personne ressource pour nous éclairer et
et si tu veux nous avons enregistré la
proposition que que tu tu viens de faire
concernant le débat qui pourrait être
euh s'installer s'instituer dans sur
chaque territoire maintenant il faudrait
qu'on fasse une proposition la
délégation fasse une proposition euh à
aux collectivités euh euh aux
collectivités territoriales hein pour
qu'on ait véritablement les acteur euh
de gestion quotidienne euh comme
participant ou comme acteur comment
dirais-je privilégié merci à vous en
tout cas merci c'est un beau
travail euh je réponds euh alors
rapidement parce que je je je
souhaiterais donner la place à beaucoup
de personnes la première mesure dont tu
parles est fondamentale faire baisser
les prix de 10 à 20 % comment faire en
fait je me suis basé sur un exemple
simple on a auditionné euh un groupe qui
s'appelle enfin c'est agouti en Guyane
d'ailleurs il a eu beaucoup de mal pour
s'installer et justement parce que les
grands groupes ont ont bloqué et le
foncier appartient à l'État et l'État
n'a pas joué le jeu il s'est retrouvé
avec un foncier éloigné des grandes
zones et pourtant il a les mêmes comp
contra d'insularité d'éloignement les
mêmes contraintes de commande publique
de pas publique de commande
d'approvisionnement pardon et il a
réussi à vendre 20 % moins cher en guyan
donc c'est possible ça veut dire quoi si
c'est possible pour lui c'est possible
pour nous ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est de dire je veux négocier
avec les grands groupes je répète parce
que là je pense que pendant des dizaines
d'années les grands groupes ont fait des
bénéfices colossaux et que il est temps
que aujourd'hui dans le contexte
actuelle de Vicher qu'il baissent les
prix de 20 % d'eux mêm sur l'ensemble
des produits mais ça doit être négocié
donc il faut les amener sur une table
ronde et les amener à négocier d'accord
parce que pour le moment l'état n'est
pas prê à leur imposer mais comme on va
pas imposer on passe d'abord par une
étape amiable de négociation et de
discussion l'État a un rôle de
régulateur aujourd'hui les grands
groupes ne peuvent pas prendre en otage
et emprisonner les peuples et les
population de notre territoire je pense
à way en Polynésie par exemple parce
qu'il y a pas on parle souvent mais way
c'est pareil c'est
pareil c'est Van alors win s guyan
alors ah on dit ouais ouais on dit al
non moi je prononce c'est la
prononciation pardon pardon en
polynésien on dit van donc moi j'ai dit
oui excusez-moi j'ai pas bon donc c'est
très clair c'est c'est voilà c'est et
c'est valable on a tous dans dans nos
territoires respectif des fois c'est les
mêmes monopoes oligopole que la CM g 80
% il y a pas photo quoi c'est c'est
voilà c'est partout ça c'est mais des
fois c'est différent alors c'est Van moi
j'appelle win je le dis win en en
Polynésie maintenant sur bon ma réponse
est claire je pense sur ça donc il faut
y aller aujourd'hui surtout dans le
contexte actuel parce qu'il est explosif
la crise social et à nos portes s'il y a
pas des actions combinées associé
d'augmentation des revenus de baisse des
prix et d'investissement massif pour
pouvoir derrière devenir plus autonome
moins indépendant de l'extérieur et
créer de la richesse locale pour
justement être en exportation en
capacité d'agir pour nous-même par
nous-même pour nous-même pour nous peup
par notre propre richesse intérieure
créée par notre propre intelligence et
par notre propre modèle économique que
nous construisons ensemble réunis et tu
as compris en tant que partenaire si on
ne fait pas ça on va être dans la
dépendance permanente vous savez c'est
confusus qui disait je te donne du
poisson je te donne du poisson donc oui
mais quand je donne une poisson je donne
une poisson tout le temps donc tu tu
n'apprends jamais à pêcher donc tu moi
je préfère t'apprendre à pêcher que te
donner du poisson parce que final en te
donnant du poisson tu es dépendant à vie
tu es dépendant à vie moi je t'apprends
à pêcher donc l'idée c'est que pendant
10 an oui il y a un truc massif qui se
fait et que derrière on puisse devenir
autonome par notre capacité endogène à
créer avec un projet local et la
deuxième question que j'aias posé
c'était sur comment on règle le problème
des concentrations ben aujourd'hui c'est
un schéma et là on est d'accord les
moyens de l'État aujourd'hui sont quasi
inexistants par rapport à l'ampleur je
dis pas cas par rapport à l'ampleur de
la consolidation des concentr au PM pas
de moyen Marg revenu sont courant de
rien délégal la concurrence bon il a un
nom un Prom c'est tout je l'aime bien et
gentil mais ça va pas plus loin la
DGCCRF quelques moy de contrôle sur les
prix ok l'Autorité de la concurrence il
n'a pas la vision claire aujourd'hui
parce qu'il gère l'autoritéence sur la
France qui est déjà un gros morceau sans
beaucoup de moyens alors les AR il
travaillent mais par segmentation et
comme en plus ce que je disais comment
ils ont réussi à détourner notre regard
je le dis les grands groupes sont
comment ils ont mis des dizaines de
petites entreprises vous allez voir un
grand groupe les seuls qui sont les
moins complexes à comprendre c'est le
clair c'est beaucoup plus simple à
comprendre dans l'organigramme mais les
autres grands groupes c'est des dizaines
de très petites entreprises de 6 10
salariés peut-être pas plus d'accord
donc ils font des petites marges mais
c'est l'accumulation du marge qui pose
problème c'est pas la marge
effectivement petite marge dit oui mais
ça marge est raisonnable d'ailleurs
l'Autorité de la concurrence 2019 la
marge est raisonnable par entreprise
mais qu'est-ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
que les entreprises ont des noms
différents et on ne connaît pas le papa
et la maman je disais toujours ça parce
qu'en fait il faut regrouper les enfants
du même groupe et ça l'État n'a pas fait
ce travail là on n pas de référentiel
aujourd'hui comment vous voulez mesurer
une concentration d'un grand groupe
alors que vous ne connaissez pas le
poids et vous ne connaissez même pas
l'ensemble des enfants qui constituent
ce groupe comment vous pouvez mesurer
son niveau de concentration donc il faut
des moyen 1 mais de il faut agir aussi
et clairement il faut modifier le code
du commerce le Code de la Consommation
le code de la concurrence et agir aussi
sur des mesures qui existent dans la loi
luelle qui n'ont jamais été appliqué la
pratique restrictive de concurrence n'a
jamais été appliquer donc il faut
rentrer dans des mesures d'application
mais il faut aussi diminuer le besoin de
standard des preuvve l'Autorité de la
concurrence nous disait oui mais parce
que ça tout fa des grand groupes onont
des millions d'euros ils prennent des
avocats hyper spécialisés et nous en
état on est tout tout réduit l'autorité
la concurrence de la Polynésie qui a une
volonté majeure mais elle se retrouve
coincée face à des grand groupes qui ont
plus de moyens plus de puissance donc
vous voyez quand je disais qu'ils sont
plus forts que les que l'État quand je
dis l'État c'est l'état local enfin les
pas dit l'état local l'autorité
locale pas mélanger les choses jeis pas
je pas l'autorité locale ils dont plus
de poids et donc derrière si on ne
modifie pas le code de la concurrence le
code du commerce le Code de la
Consommation ensemble et qu'on les
adapte à nos réalités on ne pourra pas
effectivement parce que tant que les
règles ne seront pas changé ces modèles
vont continuer à perdurer en toute
connaissance de code et en toute
impunité et en toute
injustice je vais si si juste répondre
quelques mots sur la première question
parce qu'en fait les deux sont imriqués
en
réalité et avec une part une part de
chosesù je suis plus circonspect que que
le rapporteur mais c'est normal il des
choses sur lesquelles je suis totalement
d'accord euh je crois on
peut accentuer la démarche du bouclier
qualité-prix et demander au groupe en
effet de de de de baisser leur marge et
de peser sur les prix ça peut être un
vecteur de basse des
prix peut-être aussi peut-on se dire qu'
une sorte de vanité à la chose et qu'on
narrivera pas jusqu'au bout de
l'exercice comme ça je crois qu'il y a
un effet important de baisse des prix
avec l'évolution des normes quand on a
les tableaux de correspondance de normes
qui permettent d'acheter plus près
d'acheter moins cher bah à la fin ça se
retrouve aussi sur les prix toutêtement
c'est aussi bête que ça mais quand on
parle en particulier du logement moi on
m'a donné des d'exemple du fer à béton
euh à la Réunion euh où Ctait avec toi
je sais plus enfin bon je plus non
c'était pas c'était pas la ré société le
faer Méon qu'on peut pas importer de de
d'Afrique du Sud parce que il y a une
norme qui est pas exactement la même
alors que c'est exactement les mêmes par
ailleurs donc là on a on a un vrai
oui c'est voilà c'est ça qu' un alretour
donc c'est pire encore donc là
l'adaptation des normes l'adaptation des
normes est fondamentale et je pense que
ça peut peser sur les prix et puis là où
je suis totalement d'accord avec Johnny
c'est que il y a un problème
d'insuffisance de moyens avec le sur sur
la sur les autorités de la concurrence
et que le fonctionnement normal du
marché n'aboutira peut-être pas à avoir
une équence des prix avec des marchés
beaucoup plus larges mais néanmoins doit
permettre de baisser aussi
structurellement le les prix par par le
respect des règles qui font que il y a
une concurrence qui soit saine et qui
soit pas très souvent faussée comme
c'est làdessus maintenant voilà il y a
c'est l'ensemble de ces facteurs qui
peuvent permettre de faire évoluer les
prix je pense néanmoins que il qui a un
problème de baisse des prix mais il y a
aussi un problème de hausse des revenus
en particulier pour les personnes les
plus en
fragilité pe juste préciser quelque
chose par rapport à à ce que la question
qui est posée quand soit très clair il y
a une temporalité hein la question de la
modification des normes il faut la faire
ça ça fait partie des propositions mais
le temps que les modifications de norme
arrivent aujourd'hui on a un problème
urgent immédiat à traiter donc pour le
traiter immédiatement il faut bloquer
les prix des produits de première
nécessité et là je suis j'ai une
différence avec lui on peut on a la loi
autorise le préfet localement à bloquer
les prix de produits de prire nécessité
je nous invite à demander et à insister
pour que l'État le fasse sur au moins
3000 produits le temps que justement les
autres mesures viennent et prennent les
effets et le deuxème la proposition de
baisser les prix de 20 % sur toutes les
références c'est aussi immédiatement
c'est-à-dire on se donne 12 Mo mais on
descend le temps que les autres mesures
d'investissement qui seront à plus moins
plus long terme puisse porter leur effet
parce qu'il faut qu'on soit très
réaliste dans les ce qu'on va mettre en
place parce que on est parti surous des
propositions mais les mettre en place et
faire modifier la loi modifier les
normes il a je rappelle qu' aussi des
normes européennes donc il aur un
travail à faire avec les députés
européens sur ça donc le temps qu'on
mett en œuvre tout ça l'équivalence des
normes aujourd'hui le peuple ne peut pas
attendre donc la mesure de baisser les
prix de 10 à 20 % c'est l'urgence
c'est-à-dire une mesure à très très
court terme
ok merci chers collègue le collègue
serva demandz la
parole je suis breve elle avait il y a
deux personnes av moi qui avaient
demandé président pardonne-moi vas-y ok
pas de souci
oui Président je serai très brve merci
on on parle beaucoup économie on est
beaucoup sur l'aspect économique je
voudrais mes chers collègues vous
alerter quand même sur le fait que même
si on travaille sur le bouclier
qualité-prix si on fait un blocage des
prix de première nécessité il faudra
absolument absolument veiller à la
qualité des produits la qualité
nutritionnelle des produits qui seront
mis dans ce bouclier parce que c'est ce
sera ensuite un problème de santé
publique que nous aurons à traiter et là
ce sera peut-être bien trop tard vous
savez que malheureusement les
ultramarins sont sujets à des maladies
chroniques qui sont souvent provoquées
par des conditions de vie compliquées et
une alimentation malheureusement qui est
déséquilibrée donc on parle économique
c'est très bien mais ça ne doit pas nous
faire occulter
l'aspect nutritionnel et l'aspect de
santé publique voilà j'en ai terminé
merci merci collègue petit c'est qui
l'autre personne avant le collègue serva
c'est la collègue de
polynisie je c'était toi le pas parce
queèchin son gentil ouis donc je
voudrais remercier donc tous les deux là
pour euh pour le rapport euh j'avais
exactement la même remarque que que mode
euh en Polynésie on a déjà des produits
de première nécessité avec des des prix
donc bloqués et on a cet effet cette
liste de produits c'est c'est c'est pas
des bons produits du tout donc il faut
faire très attention parce
que les les petits euh et ben ne ne se
nourrissent que de ça et ça ça impacte
donc ben toutes les maladies qu'on qu'on
connaît le diabète la goutte enfin voilà
et et aussi a un effet pervers c'est que
bah les les grands distributeurs ils
augmentent sur le reste et comme c'est
des fois des articles dont un foyer ne
peut pas se passer alors ils se il ils
sont contents enfin ils se montrent la
vitrine c'est on a baissé les prix sur
les produits de première nécessité mais
il y a aussi des produits qui sont ils
sont pas décelés comme première
nécessité mais qui sont quand même on va
dire nécessaires et là ils font des
grosses marges donc il y a des effets
pervers il faut il faut faire très
attention au au choix des des produits
on essaie là actuellement avec le le
gouvernement de de varier et de de de
privilégier les produits bah locaux
justement et donc voilà donc c'est c'est
un truc qu'il faut faire très attention
après je voulais dire pour pour les
l'augmentation des des revenus euh je
suis actuellement sur un un dossier
important mais on on se bute
avec avec le le gouvernement on va dire
sur la fonction publique et les pensions
aussi hein il y a il y a donc les actifs
mais il y a aussi les pensions et on a
en Polynésie en tout cas dans le bassin
Pacifique une perte de revenus
incroyable entre on n' pas le même taux
de remplacement pour un fonctionnaire
pensionné euh en outremaire et un
fonctionnaire pensionné retraité en en
hexagone et alors que tout ce que
demandent les partenaires sociaux c'est
de de payer les mêmes d'avoir le même le
même taux de remplacement bon je vais
pas être trop technique hein mais en
tout cas ça c'est une chose qui qui est
en train d'être négociée même pas qui se
négocie plus avec le gouvernement
puisque ils ont décider de de passer à
un autre dispositif euh et qui qui me
paraît injuste voil donc ne pas oublier
les pensionnés
aussi merci cèue
doncèin et après cè oui merci beaucoup
merci président bonsoir mes
chers collègues je vourais je serais
très bref je voulais juste vous
féliciter pour ce travail à chaque fois
que s'attaque à la question de la vie
chè de la formation des prix et de le
niveau c'est toujours une tâche
extrêmement ardue et le chemin qui
conduit au rapport et et combien
difficile donc je vous félicite une fois
de plus bien que mon collègue qualifi
est déjà fait mais pourquoi parce que je
sais ce que c'est d' chaque fois que
l'on interroge un certain nombre de
distributeurs de grands distributeurs
puisque j'ai eu l'occasion pendant
plusieurs années d'être rapporteur sur
le budget des autres mères et quasiment
à chaque budget on avait un rapport sur
la vie chè donc j'ai parcouru pas aussi
je veux dire aussi profondément pas sur
la même distance mais j'ai abordé ce
genre de sentier comme vous alors tout
de même je voudrais vous
poser une petite question vous dites que
par les négociations ils vont on va
aboutir à la baisse des prix alors qu'il
y a des négociations il y a plusieurs
négociations qui ont été entamé il y a
eu le rapport Lurel qui a conduit à des
réunions il y a le bouclier qualité prix
qui se réunit en préfecture moi chaque
fois que j'ai eu à interroger un grand
distributeur lorsque j'ai fini
l'interrogation enfin pas
l'interrogation mais l'audition j'ai eu
envie de lui de lui de chercher une
pièce de 1 € dans ma poche et en lui
disant quand vous sortirez de
l'Assemblée nationale voilà je vous
donne 1 € pour vous acheter une baguette
parce que tellement euh je veux dire il
m'avait convaincu que il était vraiment
exent
euh lorsqu'il appliquait les prix et le
bouclier qualité prix donc je suis pas
je suis parti enfin je suis vraiment
favorable à ces négociations je serais
parti pointinante si vous m'y invitiez
ou si on m invitait en Guadeloupe mais
je ne dis que ce sera pas chose facile
et puis vous dites aussi que une
augmentation des salaires moi je suis
pour tout le monde est pour personne
n'osera dire ici je ne suis pas pour
mais comme je ne suis pas tout à fait
démagogue
ou pas seulement je vous dirait qu'une
augmentation des prix n'augmentera pas
forcément mécaniquement une une
augmentation des salaires pardon ou des
revenus nugment augmentera certes le
niveau euh de de consommation peut-être
mais vous savez aussi que ça va
entraîner puisque la demande va
augmenter ça risque d'entraîner
concomitamment une augmentation des prix
puisque il y aura qu'est-ce qui fait
l'augmentation des prix en partie chez
nous c'est aussi les revenus des
fonctionnaires les 40 % il faut le dire
aussi donc je ne dis pas je ne crimine
pas mais je dis que certains profitent
du fait qu'il y ait un certain niveau de
vie pour euh ça les économistes le
savent ce sont des calculs qui sont
faciles à faire et ça entraîne
l'augmentation de la demande augmente
souvent une augmentation de
l'offre augmentation du du coût des des
prix
pardon renchérissement de de de l'offre
donc il faut regarder dans ce sens-là
aussi et donc euh et puis vous vous
parlez du marché mes chers collègues du
marché caribéen en fait pour ce qui nous
concerne par exemple 40 millions
d'habitants et vous savez euh le
président de la République l'a dit la
dernière fois et lorsqu'il le dit euh je
ne crois pas qu'il le disent de façon
uniquement pour nous décourager ou pour
avancer vous avez un marché où les
normes pas seulement les normes mais les
couts ne sont pas les mêmes et donc pour
aller vers ces marchés et ces marchés il
faut non seulement bon la question des
normes on peut les régler échanger avec
des marchés c'estes marchés
favorablement il faut aussi que nous
ayons nous une production locale
importante qui nous permet d'entrer dans
une situation d'égal à égal si c'est
pour substituer euh aux produits que
nous importons aujourd'hui d'autres
produits
euh dans faire remarcher qui est le
nôtre nous ne sommes pas certains non
plus que nous aurons des produits de
qualité je prends un exemple
je prends l'exemple des normes
sanitaires est-ce que vous savez que les
pays qui nous entourent font leurs
propres normes
sanitaires par exemple par exemple sur
l'ignam est-ce que vous pourrez est-ce
que vous savez par exemple chers
collègues que qu' le cultive de la B de
des ignames sur des terres qui
précédemment étaient planté en banane
dans les pays d'Amérique centrale et qui
que ces ignames nous arrivent chez nous
sans les sans contrôle sans que nous
ayons les moyens de les contrôler
véritablement et nous les consommons
alors que nous nous nous exigeons la non
production de
digam de chez nous dans les terres par
exemple en guadloup martinque qui sont
des TER empoisonné donc je veux dire que
il y a tellement à faire que je veux
préfère commencer par tout ce qui serait
nor qui pourra être prise en
chargeugmentation par exemple des moyens
de contrôle tout ce que l'État pourrait
faire
d'abord mais commençons par quelque
chose mais ce que je veux ce sur quoi je
veux attirer votre attention ce sont on
peut pas dire il dans ce domaine là il y
a des choses à mettre en place nous
sommes volontaires je suis en train de
me conscientiser ch camarade ch camarade
je suis en train de me conscientiser je
te remercie et continue à travailler
ensemble mais il
a je suis
vol merci
et bien moi aussi je m'associe aux
félicitations des collègues des
présidents et rapporteur de ce beau et
lourd rapport et ces belles propositions
et je vous remercie de cet
éclairage j'ai une question euh pour
vous 1 kil de pâte produit en
île-de-fance pour arriver dans à Paris
il sort de l'usine vous avez
je dirais un camion qui le livre dans
une grande surface ce même kilo de P
pour arriver en Guadeloupe il sort de
l'usine il prend le camion il va au
Havre donc il doit être mis en contener
il prend le bateau il doit être dédoiné
il doit être livré par transport dans
une centrale d'achat puis dans une grand
face d'après les dir de ceux qu'on
interroge à chacune de ces étapes
nécessaires pour livrer ce kilot de pâte
en
Guadeloupe les
marges ne seraient pas excessivees par
rapport aux
pratiques
usuelles à chacune de ces étapes
première question est-ce que vous par
rapport à vos travaux vous confirmez le
fait que à chacune de ces étapes
les marges ne seraient pas
excessives si c'est le cas alors nous
voilà bien embêté pour penser à une
réduction des prix si ce n'est pas le
cas auriez-vous
identifié les lieux ù les étapes où ces
marges seraient anormales ou excessif
par rapport à une pratique par ailleurs
s'il vous
plaît avec votre autorisation monsieur
le Président je vais commencer par
répondre parce que j'attends coup de F
mon préfet et que du coup je vais en
profiter avant qu'il ne le fasse avec
différentses tré déjà pour dire un mot
de petit oui absolument euh si jamais il
n'y a pas une profit une mise à plat du
modèle alimentaire sur ces territoires
qui ont été profondément dénaturé par
tout ce qu'on sait pour pour les
habitudes on va au-delà d' au devant
d'une catastrophe sanitaire qui a déjà
commencé d'ailleurs en réalité et c'est
tout à fait juste je remonte le je je
vais d'abord parler à la prendre la
question du collègue
serva on aura sans doute un des accord
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y a des marges
excessives je pense qu'il y a des
pratiques non concurrentielle qui existe
et qu'il faut combattre plutôt à
l'arrivée sur les territoires qu'au
départ au départ les choses sont assez
normalisées par contre il y a un biais
sur lequel je pense qu'on peut
structurellement faire quelque chose je
pense au problème de
stockage parfois les bateaux n'arrivent
pas il y a une tempête il y a une avarie
il y a quelque chose qui se passe et là
brusquement pour pouvoir mettre en rayon
il faut avoir non pas de jours de
stockage parce que il y a le camion
suivant qui arrive qui arrive de la de
de l'usine mais c'est le bateau suivant
ça peut être une semaine ça peut être de
semaines le foncier disponible sur les
territoires ultramarin quel que soit les
les territoires est un foncier contraint
et donc les coûts de stockage sont
importants est-ce que et là pour le coup
il y a sans doute quelque chose à faire
en lien avec les collectivités avec les
chambes de commerce et industrie ch les
chambres des métiers de façon et
évidemment les les structures portuaires
pour pouvoir comment on peut réguler
différemment ce stockage qui à mon sens
est un coût qui n'est pas toujours
lisible mais qui est un peu en D de s
parce que ça narrive qu'au moment où
mais il faut bien le lisser à un moment
donné euh le après il y a sans doute un
effort à faire sur les marges et
vérifier qu'il y a pas en effet des
biiais sur la concurrence on a vu qu'il
y avait des évolutions qui étaient entre
autres les plateformes de de de d'achat
des grandes surfaces et des grandes
enseignes est-ce que ça a profondément
modifié le la composante du prix moi je
n'ai pas le sentiment je pense que le
rapporteur aura un avis un peu différent
là-dessus sur les sur les effets sur le
sur le prix prenons le cas du logement
si nous arrivons à avoir des modes
d'approvisionnement différents sur les
territoires ça a un effet sur les prix
du logement et le logement est un est
fondamental dans le dans la structure de
dépenses des ménages il s'agit pas d'en
rabattre par rapport à la qualité ni à
la sécurité évidemment mais il s'agit
aussi d'ouvrir et d'avoir des tableaux
de correspondance qui permettent que oui
le président de la République a raison
par nature de ma part évidemment un
autre commentaire vous surprendra
énormément mais je pense qu'il a raison
quand il dit que la concurrence avec les
autres territoires environnant est très
compliqué parce que les coûs les coûts
ne sont pas les mêmes parce que nous
avons un modèle social qui est bien
supérieur aussi et on sait pourquoi les
coups sont différents mais quand saint
Lucy dit que les croisières peuvent
arriver dans leur port parce qu'il y a
des plateformes médicales de niveau
européen autour de qui il parle il parle
de la Guadeloupe et il parle de et il
parle de la Martinique et je vais mettre
en PR parce que je crois que c'est mon
préfet qui m'appelle mais je reprendrai
après je laisse je vous laisse entre les
mains de de de
John je suis très heureux de ces
questions parce que je pense qu'il faut
vraiment aller au fond et on va
peut-être
éclairer les autres pas vous hein je
pense que vous êtes éclairé vous
connaissez vous vivez le quotidien mais
il faut éclairer les autres faut
éclairer le président de la République
faut éclairer le gouvernement la
première ministre tout celles et ceux
qui décident tu veux que je te laisse
terminer ou je veux bien je vous prie '
excusez hein c'est pour l'aspect
chaotique donc ce que je voulais dire au
travers de cet exemple de saintelcie je
peux le reproduire sur d'autres exemples
oui par rapport à des production de base
n ne seront pas toujours concurrentiel
et il faut pouvoir se protéger par
rapport aux normes sanitaires ça c'est
évident sur les produits agricoles sur
les produits premi nécessités et cetera
mais en terme de service en terme de
service quand on veut être sûr d'être
soigné par un médecin qui a en effet le
diplôme de médecine si on veut des
infirmiers qui on diplôme et qui ont pas
acheté ça sur internet je suis désolé
être dans un état de droit qui
correspond au au territoire français ça
du sens et je pense que de ce point de
vue les les territoires ultramarins
français peuvent être leaders
surensemble de domaines dans
l'environnement régional parce qu'il y a
cette garantie là parce qu'il y a cette
garantie de formation et cetera
évidemment là je rejoins ce que disait
Johnny hajard tout de suite on n'est pas
sur un truc où le claquement de Doig
suffira à transformer la situation mais
il faut que à mon sens que résolument on
s'engage en cette voie làà par la
formation par le par un de garantie
parce que cela permettra en effet de de
de de pouvoir pouvoir en effet produire
des rich rich qui vont soutenir les
revenus après je crois qu'il aussi des
problèmes d'accès au droit il y a trop
de d'ultramarin qui de fait ne
méconnaissent leurs droits ni ont pas
accès et je crois que que la puisance
publique dans son ensemble collectivité
locale comme comme État devrait rentrer
dans une démarche encore plus forte
d'aller vers pour que des personnes les
plus en fragilité les plus isolé
puissent ne serait-ce qu'avoir la
connaissance de leur droit et pouvoir en
bénéficier merci les questions que vous
AZ vous posé tous CEL et toutes sont
tellement fondamentales que vous
m'excusez je vais répondre rapidement
sur la question des pattes et je suis
tombé dans le même piège et c'est
dommage parce que j'ai compris après
avoiruditionné un dirigeant de
GBH qui m'a expliqué qu'un conteneur de
pâte arrivait que ça revenenait plus
cher machin mais en fait là où on nous
trompe je le dis comme je le pense parce
que c'est pas honnête de faire ça comme
ça on est dans le souhisme je vais vous
prendre cet exemple là vous connaissez
la grenouille qui a quatre pattes et
puis on lui on lui dit je te coupe une
première patte saute la grenouille
sportive elle saute elle a trois pattes
on lui coupe une deuxième pâte on lui
dit sautei elle est dangereuse elle est
sportive elle saute on lui coupe une
troisième pâte on lui dit saute la grenu
c tout elle saute on lucoutte la 4è pâte
on lui dit saute mais grenu ne saute pas
elle a plus de pâte
conclusion quand on coupe les quatre pas
d'une genouille elle devient
sourde vousvez avez entendu c'est
exactement dans ce schéma là ce que tu
vois n'est pas la réalité de la cause je
vais t'expliquer moi c'est quoi le
problème ils ont souvent mis en avant ce
conteneur de pâes en fait comment il
nous trompent très simplement un il
commande pas de conteneur de pâte les
conteneurs sont groupés ils mettent des
produits à fautete valeur ajoutée des
produits à fa valeur ajoutée partout
dans chaque conteneur qui débarque donc
ils équilibrent leur coût
d'approvisionnement au départ même ce
n'est pas vrai qu'il a un conteneur de
pâes il y aura des pâes il y aura des ce
qui fait que à la fin il compense donc
il faut arrêter mais si j'avais su ça
avant ça m'est venu après ça m'est venu
2 jours après l'avoir écouté si ça je lu
posé la question d'audition mais on
réfléchissant c'est ce qui me dit je me
dit mais en fait c'est là où il nous
couillonne elle a raison ma collègue de
Polynésie quand il baissent d'un côté
ils augmentent de l'autre parce qu'en
fait ils ont 40000 il faut pas regarder
les choses individuellement faut pas
regarder un produit c'est là où on nous
fait avoir on se fait avoir il faut z la
totalité de ce qu'ils ont ils ont 40000
références ils ont une concentration
verticale maîtrisée consolidé ils ont
une concentration horizontale vous savez
c'est quoi horizontale c'est dans toutes
les activités autres outillage sport
culture voiture ils ont aussi la
maîtrise de tout ça donc derrière ils
sont des faiseurs de prix déterminés et
définitif les marges ne bougent pas
d'ailleurs ils dépensent pas leur compte
si t si transparent que ça dans ce qu'il
te disent donc à déposer leur compte
pourquoi est-ce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
demande j'ai posé à sa fou j'ai posé on
me fait voir le secret des affaires
secret des affaires des qui ça D qui ça
auè puisque l'argent que tu fais c'est
grâce au peuple au populations des
autres mè faut arrêter avec ça donc là
il faut modifier la loi pour leur donner
une pénalité parce que il préfèrent
payer l'amende aujourd'hui il payent
l'amende il payent l'amende pour ne pas
déposer leur compte on est sur des
milliards d'euros ils s'enrichissent
historiquement je les empêche pas de
s'enrichir mais pas sur le dos de nos
peuples nos populations qui
s'appauvissent il y a un problème donc
donc la réponse sur ça est très claire
les pattes moi je suis pas sophiste
parmi eux c'est des sophistes ils
prennent une mauvaise hypothèse ils en
font une bonne conclusion et ça rentre
dans nos têtes mais il faut sortir du
sophisme le deuxième point qui est très
important et là tu as tu l'as dit
collègue augmentation des revenus donc
augmentation des prix mais oui mais si
j'augmente pas les revenus je reste
aussi les gens ne pourront pas s'en
sortir faut faut savoir ce qu'on veut
attends je te dis pas ça comprends-moi
comprends comprends ce que je te dis je
ne dis pas
il faut pas faire attention aux
conséquences de l'augmentation des
revenus parce que derrièurs il faut
contrôler les prix justement c'est là où
le travail une régulation des prix pour
empêcher justement parce que que le prix
augmente sur le champagne que le prix
augmente sur le caviard bon je veux dire
à la hgur en soit ceux qui peuvent
consommer du champagne et du caviard ben
ils vont l'acheter au prix toute façon
ils ont l'argent pour le payer mais le
prix ne peut pas augmenter sur les
produits de première
consommation faut pas m'expliquer ça
faut arrêter ce jeu tu veux achèter une
Jaguar tu achètes ta Jaguar tout le
monde ne pourit pas se payer une Jaguar
ni même une journée d'esence de Jaguar
donc je suis pas au niveau des très aisé
je suis au niveau de ceux qui doivent
pouvoir donc il faut augmenter les
revenus faut je je refuse d'entendre
dire oui oui la prime de V cher augmente
les prix la prime de viechè augmente le
pouvoir d'achat de la personne qui quand
elle pouvait consommer 100 elle peut
consommer 200 parce que pour vivre comme
ça coûte plus cher il faut augmenter le
le revenu et je propose par contre là où
il y a inégalité je suis d'accord c'est
qu' on a augmenté la prime de VI ch pour
les fonctionnaires mais pour les privés
on les a laissé à terre ça veut dire
quoi qu'il y a une inégalité intérieure
qui s'est constituée historiquement où T
cell et ceux qui travaillent dans le
privé eux subissent donc je propose 20 %
d'augmentation dans le privé financé
comment pas financé par la charge des
entreprises es-mêm financé par une taxe
sur les grands groupes comme la CM CGM
comme Orange comme les grand groupes GBH
et C qui vont
financer cette augmentation de salaire
de 20 % sans toucher les charges des
petites et moyennes entreprisees et là
tu augmentes tu fais un système virtueux
on est dans un système aujourd'hui
vicieux et qui n mène vers le bas il
faut changer le paradigme et passer un
système virtueux et vous savez quoi les
grand groupes ont plus à gagner le pire
c'est que ils vont être gagnants parce
que si vous consommez plus finalement
c'est eux qui maîtrisent l'économie
aujourd'hui ils vont qu même pouvoir
gagner plus d'argent donc c'est de
l'argent qui va circuler c'est pas de
l'argent qui est tésorisé c'est de
l'argent qui circule et qui permet à
l'économie de veut devenir plus
puissante et ça me paraît fondamental
alors sur le président de la République
et la question de la diplomatie
territoriale là oui je suis désolé mais
pour moi à Laur je le considère comme
une faiblesse une ignorance oui c'est
vrai que on va dire le niveau social les
pays voisin est plus bas le niveau de
vie des pays voisins plus bas les normes
sont différentes mais Guillaume l'a dit
lui-même il y a une grosse différente je
vous dire un truc qui m'a choqué il y a
des produits qui sortent du par
aux Amériques qui sont pas très sont
beaucoup plus près de la Martinique et
de la Guadeloupe que de la France qui
partent à Bordeaux et qui reviennent en
Martinique voyz c'est ça la vie chè les
je vous je vous répète les produits
sortent du Para il vont à Bordeaux et
revienent en Martinique tout ça pour ne
pas faire par Martinique pas un problème
mais évidemment le transport ça va
coûter cher parce que la C c'est jamais
contente de ce système là mais c'est ça
qu'il faut changer et il y a les petits
état de la Caraïbe mais les petits États
se regroupent quand il y a le CARICOM
c'est un marché qui est plus important
les communautés d'Aglou c'est comme ça
qu'on a créé c'est pourquoi c'est par
périéquation pour aussi aider mais aussi
servir mais il y a des réalités de
spécialisation et ça ça fait partie des
mesures et et Guillaume le dit nous
avons des richesses c'est-à-dire que
nous pouvons développer un modèle
économique alternatif au modèle de
consommation et d'importation massif qui
nous permett de créer de la richesse
localement à partir de nos
spécialisations je parlerai pour la
Martinique on peut être un hien Laou
peut être unien la Guane peut être unien
par la question des dessertes aussi
c'est important un régional pas
seulement avec la France mais régionale
on peut être unien on peut être un hub
sanitaire c'est déjà le cas nous avons
une expertise à développer en matière de
recherche dans les maladies de santé
environnementale moi je défend un projet
de santé qui est le bien-être physique
mental et social avec la santé
environnementale la santé animale la
santé biologique si on a cette vision
globale on règle les problèmes de santé
publique et on peut peut être des hubs
la Polynésie a ses richesses le tourisme
peut être une richesse industrielle mais
il faut qu'on puisse développer un
programme local avec des moyens
peut-être pour démarrer d'investissement
public d'État mais qui nous permettent
ensuite de devenir autonome donc je ne
suis pas d'accord même quand nos modèles
sociaux sont différents on peut négocier
commercier a Cuba on peut négocier
commercier avec les États-Unis on peut
négocier commercial avec le Brésil moi
je parle pour nous vous vous pouvez
négocier commercial avec je je pense à
la Réunion vous négocier commercer avec
l'Afrique du Sud qu'est-ce qui vous
empêche de négocier avec l'Afrique du
Sud non mais franchement qui a une
richesse impressionnante qui est
beaucoup plus près de la France
hexagonale donc chaque territoire a à
côté de lui un continent ou une
puissance qui peut l'aider à créer sa
propre richesse par le développement
d'activité par la transformation de
matière intermédiaire par l'exploitation
et la mise en place d'une filière de
développement des richesses local
naturel je parlais d'énergie
renouvelable je parlais de biodiversité
alors la Polynésie ne peut servir que
pour les ESS nucléaires et jeard vous
pensionner la TVA que je propose de
réaffecter parce que la TVA repart en
France l' de mer reste dans nos
territoire c'est une richesse locale
créée localement qui reste localement
même si elle est basée sur l'importation
qu'il faut diminuer augmenter la
production locale mais la TVA c'est une
richesse cré localement qui est du même
niveau c'est environ milliard à peu près
dans les deux mais la TV part en France
pourquoi elle est cré local on a des
difficultés je mexcuse je
vaisiner l'impôt sur le revenu les 30%
c'est gentil de pouvoir baisser le
plafond de l'abattement
fiscal pour faire en sorte que plus de
personnes pay des impôts dans territoire
alors que la situation de la difficile
mais en plus je trouve que l'État joue
un je malin parce que ça fait 70 million
d'euros alors oui il le prennent pas
pour eux il le réinjecte dans le F
exceptionnessement ok finalement c'est
les pauvres qui financ les plus pauvres
je répète non mais ça tu vas pas changer
mon idée aujourd'hui les territoires tu
vas avir l'INC les territoires le niveau
le revenu le plus bas ce sont les
territoires d'outre on peut pas dire le
contraire c'est qui le dit c'est pas moi
qui le dit donc on prend avec des
collectivités ex pour lesquel l'État et
ça c'est pas toi c'est le gouvernement
Hollande aussi qui l'a fait il faut dire
ce qu' est en 2014 tu vois il y a pas
que faut pas je vous demande pas
d'assurer le poids de l'histoire
attention il y a une question de
l'histoire une accumulation le qu de
l'histoire et ce qu'il est mais le
gouvernement de gauche qui est arrivé a
considéré que la Martinique la
Guadeloupe la la réunion devait pouvoir
et ben partager la contribution au
redressement de la dette publique on
était assez riche et on a payé donc on a
donné moins de recettes donc les
collectivités on leur demande de faire
plus mais non moins c'est comme si je
vous disais va à Grand Rivière en
partant de for de France excusez-moi je
prends un exemple Martinique je parle de
for de France dit va à Grand Rivière je
te donne la voiture je donne les clés
mais je te donne pas l'essence tu me dis
ok c'est sympa je veux bien monter à g
rivière j'ai la voiture j'ai les clés
mais j'ai pas l'essence comment je fais
monter g rivière donc il faut je pense
que on soit clair dessus la question
aujourd'hui d'augmenter les impôts des
classes moyennes parce que c'est elle
qui paye l'impôt sur le revenu en
baissant le plafonnement c'est ça les 7
millions d'euros doivent pouvoir il faut
rétablir le plafond de l'abattement
fiscal pour que les gens restent pouvoir
consommer comme ils peuvent donc j'ai
répondu sur ça et puis le dernier point
sur la qualité je disais la TVA affecté
c'est d'augmenter les revenus pas
seulement des pensionnés des petites
retraites et des étudiants aussi pas
seulement des pensionnés pas seulement
des fonctionnaires d'État toutes les
personnes parce que le minimum
vieillesse existe mais il n'est pas
appliqué partout alors il y a des
problématiques de régime différencié 73
74 à prendre en compte aussi mais moi je
pense que la TVA affectée est une mesure
qui permettrait d'augmenter le niveau de
revenu des petites retraites toutes et
des chômeurs
aussi vous aurez compris qu'on n pas
tout à fait le même avis sur tout mais
c'est normal juste un point un point
factuel où je suis pas d'accord avec
avec Johnny je pense que la
surrémunération touche aussi le secteur
privé parce que les collectivités
locales me disent euh nous si on n pas
la rémunération les gens vont partir
privé mais les entreprises privées
disent aussi avec nous on est obligé de
payer au même niveau que la rémunération
sinon les les les les les cadres vont
dans le vont vont aller vers le public
donc là-dessus il y a une mécanique qui
est en encore une fois je pense que il y
a un fait il y a un fait acquis sur sur
rémunération qui on peut pas sur lequel
on peut pas revenir en arrière parce
qu'il y a un milliard et demi qui est
qui qui draine qui est draîné vers
l'économie ultramarine de cette de cette
façon mais pour autant il n'y a pas que
le prix le public local qui soit impacté
il y a aussi les cadres du privé qui voi
leur rémunération leur proposition de
salaire augmenter par par
cela merci chers collègue pour tout ces
belles questions et et les réponses
dynamiques de
de de collègues AG rvulté non moins moi
j'aimerais revenir sur certaines choses
alors c'est vrai qu'on parle des
territoires d'autre m dans la globalité
j'aimerais juste rappeler que tous les
territoires nous sont pas identiques
parce qu'il y a des îles et il y a un
territoire comme la guyan qui n'est pas
une île donc en matière d'espace la
guyan n'est pas contrainte par rapport à
l'espace de l'espace on connait le
problème du fondci en guyan on l'a
rappelé euh il y a beaucoup de choses
qui ont été dites que je partage après
tout état de causees il y a des dizaines
de de propositions recommandations qui
sont faites par euh par les collègues
vult et ur dans ce rapport là à nous de
nous en saisir et de savoir comment on
les fait vivre euh chacun à son niveau
dans le territoire de façon plus large
euh dans les dans les semaines à venir
mais néanmoins la question de la V chair
reste cruciale et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
hein on voit que les choses continuent
de grimper qu'on le veille ou non donc
ça veut bien dire qu'il y a un vrai
souci de ce côté-là je rappelle que
lorsque nous avons travaillé en janvier
dernier avec des universitaires on a
bien bien pu voir que il y a un système
qui est mis en place concernant nos
territoirees
cautionné volontairement
vololontairement par par l'État mais
c'est cautionné et ça permet en fait de
flécher les choses de façon très claire
donc moi je vais pas plus mtend
là-dessus euh nous sommes pas des la
peine 4 semaines on c'est bien ce en
train de se jouer euh à niveau là pour
territoire est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions de la part des des collègues
présents je vois Marana je vois euh
Christian donc Christian le Christian
Baptiste d'abord et ensuite maranaêtre
mal si
là ah je t'ai pas vu pardon j'ai vu donc
à mon tour
de à mon tour de évidemment féliciter le
président le rapporteur et tous les
membres de cette délégation qui ont fait
un travail
extraordinaire et euh et bien évidemment
comme disait euh monsieur le rapporteur
cher Johnny euh bon les constants on va
pas s dessus il faut voir euh les
solutions qui sont apportées et c'est
vrai que enfin je vais surtout rebondir
un petit peu sur euh l'intervention de
Johnny qui il y a beaucoup d'analyses et
de solutions que je partage et et quand
j'entends et quand je dis je partage
c'est aussi mon point de vue quand
j'entends en fait il faut vraiment que
notre économie soit située dans un cadre
premièrement où il y a de l'adaptation
de la flexibilité il faut qu'il y ait de
la diversification notamment
effectivement on a parlé du du tourisme
durable de de de de l'agriculture
biologique ou de la l'
grrotransformation
entre autres ou des énergies
renouvelable mais aussi évidemment un
renforcement de la coopération envers
nos pays euh voisin donc une diplomatie
régionale donc ce sont des solutions qui
bien évidemment malheureusement euh dans
le cadre dans lequel nous sommes ne
peuvent pas vraiment s'adapter qui fait
que aujourd'hui euh quelle production
parce qu''on parle effectivement
j'entends parler de grands groupes de
grands groupes euh bon effectivement
j'entends parler de formation mais en
fait lorsqu'on parle de prix aussi il
faut voir aussi qu'est-ce que nous
produisons euh et qu'est-ce que nous
produisons localement et euh mod à parl
effectivement de de qualité nous avons
effectivement énormément de produits qui
viennent d'ici et là on ne sait pas on
n'a pas la traçabilité et et quelle
qualité et et on ne sait pas exactement
ce qu'on ce qu'on ce qu'on mange donc
lorsqu'on parle de souveraineté euh
entre guillemets alimentaire pour nous
ça c'est extrêmement important euh parce
que le prix effectivement il est ce
qu'il est mais il faut voir aussi la
qualité derrière euh on peut avoir des
prix qui sont effectivement bas qu'on
baisse mais avec une très mauvaise
qualité et qui fait qu'on a même une
problématique en en terme d'éducation au
niveau même de l'hygiène et même de
l'alimentation d'ailleurs d'alimentation
qui fait que bon avec tous les
problématiques de comorbidité que nous
avons de diabète de cholestérol voilà
donc moi j'inscris effectivement cette
problématique dans une dans dans un
espace très large et et et on remarque
bien que en grande majorité concernant
les territoires ultrarin
euh je sais pas trop pour la Polynésie
française mais en fait quand vous avez
un bateau efftivement comme tu as dit
d'ailleurs il faut payer le bateau en un
seul voyage parce que effectivement
quand quand le bateau retourne on a rien
comme production donc enfin oui mais
enfin c'est quasiment rien c'est
quasiment rien et et en plus c'est et
donc ce retour et mais parce que tout
simplement nous sommes dans un système
qui fait que Ben 90 % des bateaux qui
arrivent chez nous sont 90 % 93 % 95 %
c'est pavillon français alors que nous
on ne peut pas effectivement importer
des pays qui sont à côté donc cela veut
dire
que la problématique c'est que on n pas
d'autonomie on a pas d'autonomie
économique et le problème il est là et
cette autonomie économique effectivement
elle passe parfaitement par tout ce que
je partage par effectivement cette
flexibilité cette databilité cette
diversification mais donc ce qui veut
dire que derrière il y a encore un
travail extrêmement important à faire et
les solutions qui sont proposées oui
mais est-ce que effectivement dans ce
cadre là on pourra véritablement les
mettre en pratique la question toute la
question est là et c'est que nous avons
énormément d'atout tu l'as dit c'est
vrai mais dans quel cadre qui nous
permettrait d'avoir effectivement cette
production d'abord et avoir des secteurs
clés de croissance économique des
secteurs clés qui correspondent à nos
spécificités comment faire en sorte pour
que nous ayons des prix qui
correspondent à nos propres
besoins qui correspondent à nos propres
partenaires et choisir aussi des
partenaires vers lesquels nous voulons
produire et nous voulons effectivement
exporter oui nous pouvons être des
parfaitement euh par exemple si on prend
le tourisme durable oui on peut faire
une grande promotion pour qu'on puisse
venir dans nos territoires mais comment
euh le tourisme sera efficace si il y a
les problèmes d'eau touristes qui
arrivent mais tous les 3 4 jours il y a
pas d'eau si effectivement le touriste
arrive mais son alimentation ce sont des
produits effectivement qui viennent de
l'extérieur si euh au niveau de
l'environnement nous avons une
environnement qui est dégradé et et qui
est pollué toute la question est là
aussi donc je crois que c'est un sujet
qui est vaste et qui est qui est vaste
aujourd'hui comment peut-on arriver à
mettre en œuvre les solutions qui sont
proposées dans le cadre de ce rapport
très bien
voilà
alors
collègue c'est ma d'abord collègue r Oui
alors le rapport est très riche beaucoup
de
propositions il y a des propositions qui
sont d'ordre législative d'autres qui
sont qui rel d'initiative local et
d'autres qui relèv de
négociation alors je pense que et
d'autres qui relèvent carrément de
changement de de paradigme en terme pour
ce qui concerne la construction de
société alors comment ma question c'est
qu'est-ce que que pouvons-nous proposer
pour faire vivre ce rapport pour qu'il
ne reste pas un simple rapport beau
rapport combien de 400 et quelques pages
j'en j'avais vu aussi fourni de point de
vue des propositions de l'analyse et des
perspectivesèg
moi j'avais juste une une petite
remarque sur la
sémantique parler de
surrémunération j'aimerais qu'on arrête
de d'utiliser ce mot parce que on va
finir par croire nous-même qu'on est
trop
payé c'est
tout c'est moiana c'est
ça
merana la collègue Mo de petit
oui merci président moi moi c'est enfin
je je j'entends les les propositions qui
sont faites notamment de de de
diplomatie régionale de travail avec les
pays voisins mais j'ai une question
peut-être naïve mes chers collègues mais
si aujourd'hui vous êtes déjà en en en
en difficulté
ou de faire venir en métropole pardon
dans
l'Hexagone je suis vieille de de faire
venir dans l'Hexagone les les des des
produits fabriqués sur chacun de vos
territoires comment est-ce que vous
pensez que demain il sera possible de le
faire avec les pays limitrophes les pays
voisins si vous si ça n'est pas fait
aujourd'hui tu parlais tout à l'heure
collèg Johnny de de conttainur de banane
qui repartaient simplement vers vers
Paris Le Havre et cetera mais où sont
les autres produits si vous ne les avez
pas aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
pensez pouvoir proposer demain à à à à
vos à vos voisins en fait moi cette
question pardon mais me turlupine voilà
je je je ne cesse de me la poser je suis
d'accord il y a une expertise on l'a
tous rappeler il y a une expertise sur
beaucoup de domaines parasismique et
cetera et cetera mais parlons-en
peut-être déjà dans un premier temps à à
à Paris enfin voilà il y a une expertise
il faut la vendre cette expertise
peut-être qu'il faut la vendre dans les
les constructions parasismiques par
exemple à nos voisins de de de l'arc
antillet pour ne citer que celui-là mais
au niveau des produits des produits à
quoi est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce que ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et que vous pensez que
demain il y en aura voilà c'est je pense
pas qu'elle soit si naïve que ça cette
question voilà c'est ce que je voulais
rajouter
merci je remercie toutes les questions
sont fondamentales pourquoi je dis ça
parce qu'en fait vous éveillez en moi
véritablement des réponsse qui me
paraissent évident mais qu'il faut
qu'absolument qu'on partage et toutes
les questions c'est important parce que
ce que tu dis peut-être que l'autre le
pense et dans le terme conscientisation
c'est justement lever toutes les
ambiguïés tous les doutes dans la tête
de ceux qui ne savent pas et qui doutent
j'ai plusieurs sujets parce que y a eu
plusieurs choses je vais répondre à vos
questions d'abord je vais revenir sur un
truc on a parlé du foncier tout à
l'heure et du fait que effectivement on
avait un problème de foncé pour pour
stocker les marchandises qui arrivaient
parce qu'on était étroit mais justement
qui est-ce qui possède le fonciers ce
sont les grands groupes donc ils ont la
maîtrise vous vous posez pas la question
pourquoi les les les grandes anciennes
nationales internationales multinational
française ne viennent pas dans not
territoire vous savez pourquoi ils ne
viennent pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
maîtrise du foncier ils n'ont pas la
maîtrise du savoir-faire ce sont nos
grands groupes locaux qui ont la maîce
du foncier donc ils peuvent stocker la
marchandise d'accord ce qui fait que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé comme on a
stocké la marchandise il y a eu un
stockage et à un moment donné
l'inflation est montée considérablement
en France mais elle est pas montée aussi
rapidement en Martinique en Guadeloupe
en guyan ce qui fait que l'ancien
ministre a dit oui voyez l'inflation est
moins importante je dis non non vous
savez ce qui s'est passé comme on les
stockage on avait commandé la
marchandise avec des prix ancien donc il
a fallu consommer tout ce qui avait été
stocké donc les prix n'ont pas augmenter
au moment où les prix augmenté en France
parce que comme il y a pas de
problématique de stockage en France ils
peuvent commander plus vite nous on est
obligé de commander sur 3 mois 6 mois
donc on est obligé de consommer et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé donc il
fallait consommer les produits achetés à
l'ancien prix donc vider les stocks et
quand on a vidé les stocks on recommande
de nouveaux stocks mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe les prix ont changé et là
l'inflation repart c'est ça qui est
train de nous arriver là on navait pas
une l' inflation inférieure parce qu'on
était mieux régulé parce que l'État a
mieux fait les choses on avait une
inflation inférieure parce qu'on avait
des capacité de stockage supérieur qui
fait qu'il fallait écouler d'abord le
stock avant de pouvoir commander de la
marchandise plus cher c'est ça qui nous
est arrivé donc il faut bien comprendre
cette réalité là donc maintenant je
passe derrière au sujet évoqué Christian
ce que tu dis et et même max très
important je m'adresse à
vous en toute responsabilité mais aussi
avec gravité et je parle à DESV je parle
à tous les parlementaires tout un
mode ta j'ai oublieé le prénom ENF tous
les parlementaires et et
Olivier nous avons un mandat impératif
de 5 ans sauf s'il y a des solution mais
nous avons un M impératif de 5 ans si
Dieu le veut il nous reste 3 ans et demi
d'accord nous avons entre nos mains si
on conserve une
unité d'action et un poids politique par
nos rassemblements de pouvoir peser sur
les décisions à venir pour nos
territoires pas localement directement
mais en France à Paris parce que le
pouvoir est ici qu'on le dise ou non le
pouvoir est ici ce n'est pas méchant que
de dire ça la décentralisation c'est une
chose mais nous ne sommes pas dans un
cadre aujourd'hui qui nous permet de
nous développer tu l'as dit Christian la
souplesse qu'on demande ça veut dire
quoi il nous faut déjà un plan une
feuille de route pas une feuille de de
route législative une feuille de route
globale en partenariat et en
responsabilité avec les collectivités
locales parce que qui va mettre en œuvre
tu l'as dit Max qui met en œuvre c'est
les collectivités locales c'est l'état
c'est l'initiative locale c'est pas 8000
kilm qu'on va mettre en œuvre par contre
on peut initier on peut faire bouger les
choses ici à condition d'être uni dans
le respect de nos différence dans nos
inéularités pourquoi je dis ça et et Dav
l'a dit per
alisons nos projets le projet de la
Polynésie le projet de la guadoup de la
Guyane de Mayot et cetera de la
Martinique pour cela faisons les états
généraux de la vie chè ou mettons autour
de la table c'est il faut faire ça pour
avoir une concertation la plus large
pour avoir une feuille de route sur 10
ans parce qu'il faut anticiper on n'est
pas en train de parler d'un problème
ponctuel on est en train de parler d'un
problème permanent et durable qui doit
cesser donc il nous faut un plan
d'action à court terme moyen terme et
long terme mais définir en emble en
partenariat avec les forces viv locales
avec les forces économiques en présence
avec l'État avec tout mais derrière il
faut un consensus minimum qu'on va
porter derrière la mise en œuvre max
elle est simple elle est par nous-mêmes
pour nous-mêmes ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous on a pouvoir législatif
mais comme on est en lien avec les
autorités locales on a un pouvoir
exécutif dans le contrôle et dans la
mise en œuvre et dans la régulation
parce que en tant que pouvoir public
nous avons pouvoir de réguler ce qui se
fait pour que ça soit pas l'anarchie et
que ça soit le libéralisme qui prennent
le dessus que les pouvoirs économiques
qui nous
imposent un mode de fonctionnement un
mode économique un mode de contrainte
parce que aujourd'hui on est captif et
aotage captif et aotage il faut sortir
et donc pour changer le modèle on va pas
passer de - 500 m sous l'eau à la
lumière comme ça du soleil et de
l'oxygène d'un coup on n'est pas des
magiciens et on n'est pas Dieu par
contre un accouchement c'est 9 mois pour
faire les
fruits mûir il faut d'abord Sommer
arroser et cetera je prends cet exemple
donc il y a un temps donc allons dans le
temps mettre en œuvre un projet qui nous
permette de manière déterminée engagée
et unie à faire évoluer les lignes et
nous permettre d'avoir entre mais tu
l'as dit la question de la
diversification je réponds mode à ta Ré
à ta question mais elle est simple oui
aujourd'hui nos productions locales sont
faibles volontairement historiquement on
nous a imposé un système d'
donc maintenant donnons-nous les moyens
d'augmenter nos productions locales
quand c'est possible oui donc ça va
arriver dans 3 ans dans 4 ans parce que
moi en Martinique on a un projet
d'autonomie alimentaire j'espère que
d'autres vont avoir peut-être que
d'autres ne pourront pas avoir les
matières premièr directement sur place
mais ils peuvent les importer pour avoir
des matières premières qui vont
transformer donc il y a des sujets sur
ça donc il faut augmenter la production
locale c'est l'un des éléments le plus
important il faut augmenter la
concurrence et il faut augmenter les
tailles de marché et il faut nous
permettre d'avoir des leviers locaux de
développement quand je dis leviers
locaux je m'excuse on a bien vu que
notre budget outreem de 3 milliards est
noyé dans le budget de l'État quand je
dis noyé c'est pas dire qu'on nous a
donné une demi-journée hier jusqu'à
minuit et on a discuté de T problème
excusez-moi alors oui c'est vrai que
c'est transversal il y a 20 milliards
dans la santé dans la culture il y a 25
milliards mais finalement on ne nous
permet pas de discuter spécialement par
nousmême pour nous-mêm de nos propres
projets donc peut-être qu'il faut et je
le dis je le répète personnellement je
suis pas ind dépendantiste je suis
autonomiste ça veut dire que je veux je
veux et je tiens à rester dans la
République française je suis français
par contre je dois pouvoir avoir les
moyens de libérer l'initiative locale
d'avoir un projet en dégène parce que je
pense localement je ne pense pas
français je pense Martinique d'abord et
même si je complète ma logique en disant
je suis prêt à apporter une
supplémentarité une complémentarité à la
France dans son rayonnement il y a aucun
souci par rapport à ça je veux conjuguer
l'égalité des droits et le droit à la
différence tout le monde n'est pas dans
ce même schéma là peut-être mais moi je
veux conjuguer l'égalité des droits
l'égalité l'égalité des droits et le
droit la différence pourquoi je dis ça
ici on est tous égau parce que
humainement on est ég je l'ai d dit mais
on est tous différents dans la réalité
regardez comment on est habillé regardez
ce qu'on mange ce qu'on ne mange pas et
notre mode de vie on est est différent
mais on est égau donc c'est naturel
c'est factuel donc ce que je veux dire
par là je lance un message
politique la question de l'appel de for
de France celle qu'il est indiqué ce
n'est pas pour une sorte de pouvoir pour
du pouvoir le pouvoir il est éphémère
par contre si vous avez une compétence
j'insiste je vous donne un exemple bête
vous avez la compétence de couper l'
sous 100 m vous voulez couper l' sous
200 m et ben vous êtes obligé passer par
l'Assemblée nationale pour couper 200 m
parce que vous n'avez pas le pouvoir de
modifier la règle la norme la norme qui
vous permet de couper l' s 200 m je
pense comme ça par
hasard ça veut dire que il y a des
adaptation législative
majeure il y a aussi peut-être
d'initiative de loi local majeure qui ne
sont pas contre je prends le transport
je prends cet exemple là tout bête on
est sur la l loientation sur les
transport intérie 1982 et quand on
regarde le modèle de la Louti je suis
désolé taxi parisien c'est pas taxi
martiniqu ça n'existe pas d'ailleurs
même en Guadeloupe je crois pas que le
taxi parisien existe d'accord donc on
n'est pas dans les mêmes moyens de
mobilité on n'est pas dans les mêmes
réalités de mobilité et le seul moyen de
financer le transport public aujourd'hui
par la Louti c'est le versement
transport on nous impose le versement
transport sauf que le versement
transport ne finance que même pas 50 %
le transport public que l'on veut mettre
en place ça veut dire qu'il faut aller
chercher d'autres sources de financement
sauf que la loi ne nous permet pas
fiscalement ni en terme local ni en
d'autres termes de pouvoir financer le
transport public donc il nous faut des
moyen de pouvoir adapter et dicter la
loi ce que je veux dire mais ça c'est un
notre schéma c'est beaucoup plus loin
chacun est libre mais je dis que tant
qu'on aura pas à la fois la volonté et
la détermination là dans le cadre actuel
on pourra faire des choses on pourra
faire des choses mais derrière le
programme actuel chacun est libre je je
vous entend je sais mais je parle pas
pour la Guadeloupe ni pour la Guen et
pour qu'on soit clair aussi sur un point
on ve être clair avec vous le rapport
est un rapport où chacun choisit ce
qu'il veut ce n'est qu'une base vous
êtes les acteurs de vos territoires je
ne suis pas celui qui va apporter la
solution en Polynésie en Guyane ou à
Mayot par contre je prétends être
capable d'apporter la solution en
Martinique vous
m'excuser pas seul mais en tant que
contributeur en tant que martiniica oui
je connais suffisamment pour pouvoir
dire donc donc moi ce que je veux vous
dire par là c'est que en tant que
Martinique et qui connaît la Martinique
ce que je veux pouvoir vous dire c'est
que là n avons à travers le rapport une
base qui va être enrichie parce que
finalement plus on va rencontrer des
gens plus on va discuter vous avez c'est
67 67 propositions mais au fond il y a
plus de 80 propositions dedans parceil y
a des sousprositions que je n'ai pas
mises mais on est à plus de 80 100
proposition là et vous allez les
enrichir avec les vôres l'important
c'est d'avoir une base de départ l'idée
c'est de partir de la vision globale et
à partir de la vision globale faire sa
feu de rout territoire par territoire
c'est à vous de prendre la main et DV je
je t'encourage je vous encourage jous
prenez la main dans vos
territoires personnalisez vos projets
mettons en place un plan d'action à
court terme Mo terme long terme pas qui
va se définir par le PLF hein il faut
des choses pluannuelles c'est pas un
truc sur un non on discute sur un non on
obtient si on obtient ça il faut quelque
chose de stabiliser une loi programme
sur 10 ans sur 15 ans d'accord avec des
engagements financiers et un partenariat
état collectivité locale force vive
pouvoir économique qui nous permettent
d'apporter les vraies solutions pour
augmenter les niveaux de vie dans nos
territoirees merci euh collègue Ader
pour
euh et chers collègues alors jeis vous
dire qu'il est déjà
14h03 donc on arrive à à 2 he de de
réunion si je me trompe pas en plus il y
a le collègue serva qui a une question
diverse à à faire valoir donc je nous
donne encore jusqu'à les 14h10 pour les
jeux de questions réponses en étant en
étant conci et
précis après je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous vous devrez vqu vos
occupations d'accord donc les collègues
qui ont des questions à poser j'ai vu
chrtian j'ai vu d'autres main levé mais
j'ai pas j'ai pas
reconnu
jeéaise tu VO pas parce que la Polynésie
très
loin et je viens la
place
donc je peux intervenir
oui non sur sur l'intervention de de la
collègue mode mode
petit c'est vrai que ce qui est
important avant tout c'est la ce qui
fait la force d'un territoire c'est
c'est
l'économie et ce qui fait la force de
l'économie c'est la production et que
plus la production locale et et
d'ailleurs comment on mesure la
puissance territoire c'est par le PIB le
produit intérieur brut c'est vrai qu'on
parle de prix mais sur quelle production
donc je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure sur
des productions qui viennent de
l'extérieur et pas forcément de bonne
qualité et qui peuvent nous créer toute
une série de de couité en terme de dit
mais par rapport à la question de avant
tout ce qui je pense qu' qui est
important pour les guqui c'est de
commencer par ce qu'on peut parler en
terme de souveraineté alimentaire par
exemple ou souveraineté tout court de
production c'est comment par produire
pour nous-mêmes et par nous-mêmes et
faire en sorte que nous ayons cette
production de qualité et ensuite si
effectivement par rapport à nos pays
voisins cette
production est débordante on peut
l'exporter on l'exporte bon évidemment
si elle n'est pas suffisante à ce
moment-là on peut importer mais c'est de
voir c'est de
maximiser au mieux la production locale
en fait c'est ce qui est important dans
dans un premier temps
ensuite ce qui est important aussi euh
dans dans dans ce deuxième temps et
c'est vrai que
oui c'est vrai que pour pour conclure
c'est que comme disait
Johnny les politiques publiques sont
décidées au niveau national toutes les
politiques publiques donc l'idée de dire
effectivement alors si si elles sont
décidées au niveau national oui on peut
convenir de participer effectivement à
la décision en amont de ces de ces
décisions de ces politiques publiques
notamment économiques et bien évidemment
si ces politiques publiques aussi
peuvent être décidé dans un principe de
subsidiarité c'estàd au plus proche des
territoires je pense que la la la France
est une république fédérale qui
signignore parce qu'il y a plusieurs
types de de de de je dirais de
territoire la Polynésie qui a une forme
d'autonomie la Guyane qui est
effectivement une collectivité
territoriale la Martinie qui en est une
autre la gualou qui a deux
de qui la Guadeloupe qui effectivement
département région Saint-Martin qui a
effectivement une collecti territoriale
donc ça veut dire que oui on est tout à
fait d'accord nous avons nos
particularités mais avant tout sur la
base effectivement euh de mettre en
avant notre production locale et les
politiques publiques autour de ça et
quand vous faites une production
locale évidemment si vous vous décidez
notamment nos îles basées sur le
tourisme mais ceux qui viennent et bien
ceux qui viennent ils ils verront avant
tout la ce que tu as produit ce sera ton
eau ce sera tes aliments avant tout ce
sera effectivement ton environnement
avec évidemment une certaine protection
et toute la question est là et il en
découlera maintenant effectivement des
prix correspondant à la qualité de ce
que vous
produisez cèg
maazin merci mon cher Président je sais
que c'est la chaleur
qui non je plésente non ce que je veux
dire Johnny
non on ne me voit pas non plus à l'écran
donc euh je ne pourrais pas extraire la
vidéo pour mettre invisibilité je ne
pourrais pas extraire la vidéo pour
mettre sur mon facebook donc je vais
être très sobre non ce que je veux dire
euh monsieur cher amis monsieur le
rapporteur c'est que nous avons bien
entendu mais nous prenons conscience
c'est ce que nous disions Olivier et moi
nous prenons conscience de la difficulté
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
posé le problème de la méthode pour
laquelle selon laquelle on peut arriver
on pourrait arriver à ce à ces
propositions puisque d'autres ont fait
beaucoup de de de de rapports ici à
l'Assemblée nationale don nous n'avons
pas vu euh véritablement les suites
d'ailleurs euh tu t'es référé au rapport
au l'urel donc si tu t'es référé à la
loi égalité réelle de l'urel depuis
l'urel ça veut dire que et ce n'est pas
faute pour beaucoup d'entre nous d'avoir
fait des efforts donc nous avons eu
d'illustre prédécesseur si nous prenons
l'exemple de l'urel de et d'autres que
je ne connais pas qui viennent de
Polynésie ou d'ailleurs don la nécessité
pour nous d'être extrêmement
circonspect sérieux don et de voir un
peu comment nous pouvons y aller et ce
que je disais à Olivier c'est que toi tu
as un exécutif par exemple qui est
parfaitement en accord avec toi en tant
que député en en Martinique nous ce
n'est pas forcément le cas or tu sais
que chez nous enfit pas chez nous la loi
dit
la loi prescrit que le développement
économique c'est la région par exemple
et donc nous chez nous nous avons une
région département bon peu importe c'est
une organisation que nous avons choisi
pour jusqu'à présent mais et et donc
l'initiative quand toi tu peux
déclencher une initiative parce que tu
as déjà un accord ou une une entente
cordiale à Martinique nous n'avons pas
forcément je veux dire ça veut pas dire
qu'on s'entend pas on s'entend très bien
on a travaillé sur leum ensemble mais
nous n'avons pas forcément les mêmes
orientations
ou les mêmes la même façon de voir la
question du développement c'est ce qu'on
disait on échanger là-dessus on disait
qu'en Martinique la TA proximité avec
Serge fait pose le problème différemment
que chez nous et c'est c'est la raison
pour laquelle le chemin peut-être sera
plus ardu et plus difficile très bien si
si je peux juste sur ça effectivement
pardon non vas-y vas-y enfin c'est pas
to c'est toi qui donne parole je dis
vas-y colè collègue Johnny non collègue
Johnny si tu veux le faire faisle très
court s'il te plaît oui alors très court
mais on on va en parler après max la
seule chose que je veux nous dire et il
faut parler de ces choses-là
effectivement c'est ça là aussi la
personnalisation c'est-à-dire les
différences qu'il y a par rapport à des
territoires mais mais je pense que là
simplement la réponse c'est de dire euh
on travaille au service du peuple et il
faut qu'on trouve ensemble le moi c'est
pour ça que je parle de concertation
c'est pour ça que je parle d'État
généraux on peut l'appeler autrement
peêtre autrement que état généraux mais
il faut une concertation et montrer que
tu prends l'initiative l'important c'est
de montrer l'initiative on verra après
les forces de blocage et d'obstruction
tu dois être une force de lumière
merci merci cher collègue Johnny bon je
sens bien qu'on a pas on n pas on n pas
tout dit par rapport à à ce sujet qui
est au com important donc je si vous en
êtes d'accord on pourra revenir
là-dessus sur avec une autre réunion
sous une autre forme on verra bien mais
en ce qui me concerne euh le débat est
encore euh encore très loin d'être de
terminer là-dessus et les idées je pense
feront dans la avenir très proche
Dav je suis très pur d'un débat ouvert
sur tout ça entre nous
ok pas de souci on en prend bonne note
et on verra comment on organise ça assez
rapidement en tous les cas euh je tiens
remercier euh le collègue johnnyer le
collègue vult pour ce rapport danse avec
des dizaines euh de de recommandations
de
propositions donc travail assez à qui a
été fourni en 5 mois donc merci à eux et
toutes les personnes qui on qui ont
contribué pour ce rapport donc comme on
l'a déjà dit hein à nous de nous en
saisir et de savoir ce que nous allons
faire concrètement territoire par
territoire et je pense que la la
collègue mod petit a bien résumé le tout
en posant la question qui a permis des
différentes réponses réactions diverses
et variées c'est sur mais qu'est-ce que
territoire par territoire on aura à
proposer comme transformation comme pro
produit qui permett effectivement de
sortir de ces situations donc le travail
nous incomte à nous effectivement
d'apporter les réponses àes différentes
questions comm fondamental